GOING TO GO AHEAD AND GET
STARTED AS THE SUBCOMMITTEE
WELCOME EVERYONE TO THE AUGUST
FOURTH TWO ANY TWENTY HEARING.
I'VE GOT A COUPLE OF-
HOUSEKEEPING- ITEMS THAT WE
NEED TO ADDRESS AND WE'LL GET
STRAIGHT INTO THE- AGENDA
WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY WATER
PARKS AND WILDLIFE COMMITTEE
HEARING. WILL BEGIN BY SHARING
A FEW NOTES ABOUT THE LOGISTICS
OF THE HEARING TODAY- THE STEPS
HAVE BEEN TAKEN TO HELP
PRESERVE THE SAFETY OF EVERYONE
HERE TODAY AND ENSURE THE
PUBLIC'S AXES. TO DISCUSSION.
TO BE CONTINUED STAY AT HOME
ORDER WE ARE PRACTICING
PHYSICAL DISTANCING HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM. AND DROP CAPITAL.
IN THE BUILDING. SO WE ARE ONLY
ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WATCH AND
PARTICIPATE. IN THE HEARING
HERE IN PERSON. WE'RE ALSO
REQUIRING THAT MUST BE WORN AND
PHYSICAL DISTANCE HE BE
MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TESTIFYING. WEATHER
HERE IN THE ROOM OR AT VIDEO
CONFERENCING IT'S- NOT HAVE
AMASSED WE CAN PROVIDE ONE FOR
YOU. PLEASE DON'T HESITATE TO
ASK OUR SERGEANTS HERE- FOR
PRESIDENT. WE A FEW DIFFERENT
OPTIONS FOR WITNESSES- WHO WILL
BE TESTIFYING TODAY. THREATENS
CHAMBER WE CAN ONLY ACCOMMODATE
A MINIMAL CONTINGENT OF STAFF
AND LIMITED NUMBER OF THE
PUBLIC. AND MEDIA IN ORDER TO
MAINTAIN TO SIX FEET OF
SPACING. ARE ALSO STRICT
PHYSICAL DISTANCING PROTOCOLS
FOR THE PUBLIC TO ENTER AND
LEAVE THE CAPITAL. AND FOR
THOSE HERE A IN THE ROOM AS
WELL IF ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY ON THE BILL PLEASE
RAISE YOUR HAND. WE WILL ASK
THAT YOU APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. WOULD ASK THE PUBLIC NOT
TOUCH THE MICROPHONE. YOU CAN
EXIT THE HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU
ARE DONE TESTIFYING OR RETURN
TO YOUR SEAT. PLEASE BE SURE TO
OBSERVE PHYSICAL DISTANCE IN
UPON LEAVING THE CAPITOL.
INCLUDING LIMITING ELEVATING
USED TO ONE PERSON AT A TIME.
WE WILL ALSO BE USING A
MODERATOR. FOR THE TELEPHONE
SERVICE THROUGH WHICH ANY
WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON A BILL.
THE CALL THE NUMBER FOR THIS
HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN. IN THE ACCESS CODE IS
TWO FOUR TWO. SIX TWO THREE
SEVEN YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS
NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY WATER
PARKS AND WILDLIFE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON YOUR TV
SCREEN. PLEASE CALL WHEN THE
AUTHOR THE BILL YOU PLAN TO
TESTIFY ON IS BEGINNING THEIR
BILL PRESENTATION. PLEASE DO
NOT CALL. AHEAD THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE BASED ON
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT. OR OPPOSE
THE BILL. IF YOU ARE CALLING IN
THESE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE. THIS INCLUDES NEEDING
YOUR LIFE THROUGH BROADCAST AND
YOUR SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE
SOUND ISSUES. PLEASE ALSO BE
ADVISED THAT IF YOU ARE A MAIN
WITNESS PROVIDING TESTIMONY FOR
OR AGAINST A BILL. YOU REMAIN
ON A LIFELINE AND WILL NEED TO
MUTE YOURSLF UNTIL YOU ARE
CALLED. ON TO SPEAK. IF YOU'RE
HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE
MODERATED PHONE SERVICE. YOU
CAN CALL THE COMMITTEE. AT.
NINE ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE TWO
ZERO NINE SIX. AND OUR TEAM
WILL BE THERE TO TRY TO HELP.
ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT WE ARE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY TO
THE POSITION LETTER PORTAL ON
THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE.
WITNESS TIME LIMIT IMPORTANT
FOR EVERYONE- TO TAKE NOTE OF
THIS FOR EACH BILL THERE CAN BE
UP TO TWO MAIN WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT AND TO ME WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. THESE WITNESSES
HAVE BEEN MADE KNOWN TO THE
COMMITTEE IN ADVANCE. OF THE
HEARING EACH WITNESS WILL HAVE
UP TO TWO MINUTES TO SEAK. FOR
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION.
AND POSITION ONLY. THANK YOU
FOR BEARING WITH US AS WE
IMPLEMENT METHODS TO CONTINUE
TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS WE ALL
FACE. THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE COMMITTEE MEMBERS IF
YOU'D LIKE TO RESPOND TO A ROLL
CALL ASK A QUESTION OR PROVIDE
A COMMENT. YOU'LL NEED TO RAISE
YOUR MICROPHONE SO THAT STAFF
CAN ACTIVITY WHEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK. ALSO
PLEASE STAND UP AND FACE THE
MICROPHONE WAS SPEAKING TO
ENSURE YOUR VOICE IS AUDIBLE
AND- RECORDED. A BILL
PRESENTERS WILL SPEAK FROM THE
MICROPHONE AT THE BACK OF THE
ROOM. WITH THAT LOOKS A CALL
THE ROLL TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
MR SECTOR PLEASE CALL. CALLING
THE ROLE EDUARDO GARCIA PRESENT
PRESENT. MEGAN DALLY. PRESENT
BIGELOW PRESIDENT CHOI.
PRESIDENT TO. PRESIDENT
FRIEDMAN CRISTINA GARCIA.
PRESIDENT GLORIA PRESIDENT
KALRA. LEVINE PRESIDENT MATHIS
PRESIDENT RUBIO. RUBIO PRESENT
SALAS. WOULD PRESIDENT THERE'S
A QUORUM MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
WE DO HAVE A QUORUM LET'S- TAKE
UP THE CONSENT CALENDAR ITEM
AND YOU'RE WORKING AGENDA
MOVING TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
THERE'S ONE FILM SENT COUNTER
ITEM TO AS. TWELVE THIRTY ONE.
MOTION AND A- MATHIS. NUMBER
SIERRA. UNDER QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS CONCERNS I WILL ASK
THE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON ITEM TO SB TWELVE
THIRTY ONE. SB TWELVE THIRTY
ONE THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
EDUARDO GARCIA BY THAT WATER
GARCIA HI MEGHAN DALLY. MEGAN
DALY AYE BIGELOW BIGELOW I CHOI.
CHOI AYE CHU CHIU I FRIEDMAN.
CRISTINA GARCIA AUSTIN A GARCIA
GLORIA. GLORIA I KALRA. KALRA I
LEVINE LEVINE I MATHIS. MATHIS
I BLANCA RUBIO BLANCA RUBIO AYE
SALAS. WOULD WOOD HI. THE VOTE
IS TWELVE TWO ZERO WITH TWO
MEMBERS NOT PUTTING IT. THANK
YOU. WILL MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
ITEM WHICH IS SENATE BILL
ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE AT THIS
TIME- WERE ASKED AND
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GLORIA WILL BE
PRESENT FOR CENTER STERN- AT
THE BACK OF THE- PLEASE. PLEASE
NOT A GOOD. PLEASE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN- MEMBERS AT
THIS BILL SEEKS TO ADDRESS THE
RISKS POSED TO CALIFORNIA'S BY
WILDLIFE TRAFFICKING IN TRADE
AND OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO ACT
TO PROTECT HUMAN HEALTH AND BIO
DIVERSITY. SENATOR STERN ASK ME
TO EXPRESS HIS GRATITUDE FOR
THE TIME THE TENSION AT THE
COMMITTEE STAFF PROVIDED TO HIS
BILL. YOU'D ALSO LIKE TO ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
FURTHER HE AND HIS SUPPORTERS
APPRECIATE THE SENSITIVITY OF
THIS ISSUE TOO MANY ARE
COMMITTED TO HAVING A BROADER
DISCUSSION WITH STAKEHOLDERS
ABOUT THE WELFARE OF
CALIFORNIA'S WILDLIFE. LIKE
SARS MURDER A MURDERS. MOVIE
NIGHT HAS ONCE AGAIN BROUGHT
ATTENTION TO HOW ANIMALS ARE
HUNTED TRANSPORTED AND SOLD.
THE EXACT ANIMAL PATHWAY FOR
THE FIRST TEAM IN CASE OF KOBE
TO STILL BE DETERMINED. SENATE
BILL ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE A BILL
FOCUSED ON WILDLIFE TRAFFICKING
IN TRADE. PROVIDES THE TOOLS
NECESSARY FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE. TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIANS FOR POTENTIALLY
DISEASED ANIMALS AT TO PROTECT
IMPERILED ANIMALS. AND
PRACTICES SACRAMENTO TO THEIR
SPECIES. EXISTING PROVISIONS IN
STATE AND FEDERAL LAW AND
REGULATIONS SEEK TO PROTECT
PEOPLE FROM THE RISKS
ASSOCIATED WITH DISEASED
ANIMALS. HOWEVER THERE APPEAR
TO BE GAPS IN THIS. IT SAYS THE
OFFICE THE UTILIZED. ACTIVE IN
RESPONSE AND BILL LEVIN SAID
FIVE IS THAT. FISHING WILL IF
THIRTY TO PRO ACTIVELY TO SPEND.
ANY OF THE HUNDREDS OF RESTRICT
SPECIES PER. ISSUE ANNUALLY
SHOULD THEY BE AT RISK OF MAKE
OF IT NINETEEN. WILD ANIMALS
MEN OR ZOO NOT TRANSMISSION IS
TO BE SOURCE. THE ON THE PART
OF OUR HEALTH SENATE BILL
ELEVEN FIVE WHICH A NUMBER OF
EARNS. GLOBE POVERTY CHAO. IN
THE- WHILE. THE BILL SEVEN FIVE
ALSO SIX PROTECT CERTAIN CAN
FROM TEEN BY PROHIBITING THE
RATION OF NEW TROPHIES IN THE
STATE SENATOR MAY REMEMBER SAID
STERN BILL SAID BILL FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SO AT YEARS AGO WAS
VETOED BY GOVERNOR BROWN MANY
OF US SUPPORT THAT BILL IN
AFRICAN DESTINY SHOULD NOT BE
TO HEY ON WALL THAT'S BEEN
WOULD APPLY AN IN DANGER. IN A
INCLUDING AFRICAN AFRICAN LAW
WERE LOW BY IN CERTAIN ZEBRA
WITH ME I THIS MORE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THIS LET IS MAKE
YOU SO THE SOURCE COULD
LEGISLATION AND BRENDAN COMING
WITH US FOR BY THE- GREAT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU CAN YOU HEAR ME
OK. WE CAN HEAR A- OKAY GOOD
MORNING A UNITED NATIONS STUDY
AND MADE TWENTY NINETEEN. WHICH
IS THE MOST COMPREHENSIVE
ASSESSMENT OF ITS KIND. FIND
THAT ONE MILLION SPECIES ARE
NOW THREATENED WITH EXTINCTION
MANY WITHIN DECADE. ACTUAL DATA
WAS COMPILED BY MULTIPLE
NATIONS WHO IDENTIFIED THE
THREAT OF THIS MASS EXTINCTION
NOT MISINFORMATION BEING SPEWED
BY HUNTING INTEREST TO JUSTIFY
KILLING OF MAJESTIC CREATURES
TO BENEFIT THE WEALTHY FEW. YOU
WILL HEAR FROM THE NRA THE
PARTY CLUB AND AS THE BOB WAY
REPRESENTATIVE CLAIMING THAT
THEIR TROPHY HUNTING SOMEHOW
CONSERVE THE ELEPHANTS AND
OTHER SPECIES HOWEVER THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION FOUND THAT IT
DID NOT CONSERVE THESE ANIMALS
AND BANNED THE IMPORTATION OF
PROCEEDS INTO THE UNITED STATES.
AND NOTHING HAS CHANGED ON THE
GROUND THE ONLY DIFFERENCE IS
THEIR NEW FRIEND IN THE WHITE
HOUSE. TRUMP RE BIRTH THAT
SCIENTIFICALLY BASED DECISION
WHICH HAS NECESSITATED THAT
CALIFORNIA TAKE THAT STEP. THE
BALL COULD THAT HONEY BEES GO
TO THE LOCAL POPULATION IS A
MESS WHEN IN FACT THEY GO TO
THE OUTFITTER LANDAU AND
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS. LOCAL
MAKE MONEY OFF BIGELOW TOUR AND
COME NOT TROPHY HUNTING.
HUNTING HAS BEEN FALSELY
LABELED AS A CONSERVATION TOOL
YET HERE WE ARE IN THE MIDDLE
OF A MASS EXTINCTION WE CANNOT
KILL OUR WAY OUT OF IT AND SAID
YES KILLEEN WILL CONCERT IS ONE
OF THE GREATEST ALLIES OF OUR
TIME. OUR WORLD IS FACING TO
MATCH OF. PLAGUE ANNEKE. AT THE
ELEVENTH FIVE ATTEMPT TO
ADDRESS BOTH AS FAR ONE STATE
CAN GO. AGAIN YOU THE MAN FELL
FOUNDER AND PRESIDENT OF SOCIAL
COMPASSIONATE LEGISLATION
COSPONSORED OF SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY FIVE. AND I URGE YOU TO
VOTE I ON THE BILL THANK YOU.
SO MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
JUST WANTED TO GOOD MORNING NOT
PREGNANT COMING FOR THE FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY
INTERNATIONAL WILDLIFE TRADE
POSES A SIGNIFICANT THREAT TO
CALIFORNIA IN THE WORLD
BIODIVERSITY AS WELL AS I
PUBLIC HEALTH AND BY EXTENSION
OUR ECONOMY. ABOARD THE TWO
HUNDRED MILLION LIVE ADAM WILD
ANIMAL ARE IMPORTED INTO THE
UNITED STATES EACH YEAR MANY OF
THE SUCH TO THE GLOW WHILE
TRADE ITEMS HIGHLY IN. ANGOLANS
AN AFRICAN EL ARE. FOR OTHER
SPECIES. REPRESENTATIVE TO NATO
WILDLIFE. FOR EXAMPLE IN
CALIFORNIA OPRAH WERE FOR TWO.
HAVE BECOME ESTABLISHED IN A
WHILE DISPLACING OUR NATIVE.
AND CARRYING TO THE THAT THAT
DENTIST. NATIVE AMPLE. TO MAIL
OR MORE BILL PULLED FROM ARE
IMPORTANT. EACH YEAR EVEN
THOUGH OUR NAY STATE HAVE BAD.
DID THAT IMPORTED WHAT CARRIER
NOT AFFECT NATIVE WHY. BUT ALSO
TO. GLOBALLY A QUARTER OF THE
THAT FROM INFECTIOUS DISEASE.
ABOUT 2% OF THE TO THE ARE
CONSIDERED CLEAN NOT. MEANING
THEY JUMPED FROM OTHER ANIMALS
TO PEOPLE AND MORE THAN SEVENTY
PER OF THE NOT A TO THE
ORIGINATE WITH WILD. CO
NINETEEN ALMOST CERTAINLY A- IN
A BACK MAY THE JUMP TO ANOTHER
SPECIES. LIKELY PANGOLIN AN
FROM THERE TO AND ALL LIKELY
OCCURRING A LIVE AT PARK. THE
CODE MAY OUTBREAK LEAD NEW OR-
INCLUDING ELEMENT OF THE U. S.
AND THE WHL CALL FOR. ARE ON
THE LINE WILDLIFE TRADE. THIS
BILL ADDRESSES TO ACT OF THE
WHILE LIKE TRADE. I PROVIDING
THE POSSESS APPROACH OF TO MOST
IMPAIR WILDLIFE SPECIES. ASSIST
ELEPHANT AND OUT AND BY RICK
THAT THE LIGHT WILDLIFE
IMPORTANT THE STATE. I CAN.
UPON A DEMONSTRATION THAT THE
ANA COULD NOT AT THE TO THE
RISK TO PEOPLE OR NATIVE
WILDLIFE. AND WE BELIEVE THAT
THAT IS A CRITICAL STEP IN
REDUCING THE- REST BUT THE
TRADE BECAUSE TO THE PEOPLE
WILDLIFE CAN. THANK. THANK YOU
MUCH I DID WANT TO TAKE NOTE
THAT WE'VE BEEN. TOLD THAT THE
STREET A STRIP THE HAVING
TECHNICAL. AND SO WE BE A- WORK
THROUGH THOSE AS WELL AND THE
CALL IN NUMBER DIEM F PEOPLE
CALLING IS FOR SO I JUST WANTED
ACKNOWLEDGE IN THAT WERE
WORKING ON THOSE ATTACK ISSUES
TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE HAS
BOTH. A TO THE ME AND TO
PROVIDE INTO. AT THE OTHER I
WANTED TO JUST HIGH THAT WE DO
HAVE. STATE SENATOR HENRY
STERN- AVAILABLE IN THE QUEUE
TO ADDRESS ANY QUESTIONS. THAT
MAY ARISE IT TO REQUIRE THE
DIRECTOR TO A- HIMSELF. I'M
GOING TO CONTINUE WITH THE
SUPPORT. THE BILL HAVE ANYONE
IN THE ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO.
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE PLEASE COME FORWARD.
SEEN NO ONE IN THE ROOM IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE REMOTE
AREAS OF THE STATE OR IN THE
CAPITAL- IN THE QUEUE.
MODERATOR FOR TESTIMONY. IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB ONE ONE SEVEN FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. THERE ARE BE JUST ONE
MOMENT FOR FIRST LINE THANK YOU.
OVER LINE ONE FORTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION
PLEASE. TERMINATE RACHEL MY
NAME IS CONSTANCE FRANKLIN I AM
A CALIFORNIA RESIDENT CALLING
FROM LOS ANGELES AND I
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT- BE
ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE IT'S THE
ONLY ETHICAL CHOICE THANK YOU
THAT CAN BE MADE. THANK YOU
OVER A LINE SIXTY PLEASE CALL I
HAD. THE SUPPORT AFTER THE ONE
ONE SEVEN FIVE. THANK YOU WHAT
A LINE ONE FORTY THREE SCORE I
HAD. MORE IN THE FUTURE BOB
ROBINSON WAS SHOT TO SHELTER
LIKE I'LL BE HAPPY SOCIETY OF
THE UNITED STATES AS WELL AS
CAL ANIMALS IN SUPPORT OF THE
LEGISLATION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WHAT ARE COMBINED ONE OH
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING AND NUMBERS DOESN'T
BOTHER NOT LIKE HOW PUBLIC
CALLING ON BEHALF OF ANIMAL
LEGAL DEFENSE JOHN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU JUST
WANTED TO ALL ANNOUNCED THAT
THE STREAM OF THE CONFERENCE IS
BACK UP. IT'S GOING TO. THANK
YOU OF OUR LINE SEVENTY THREE
PLEASE CALL I HAD. HI THIS IS
THE GAINEY PERHAPS FROM LOS
ANGELES I'M CALLING TO EXPRESS
MY SUPPORT FOR SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY FIVE AND STRONGLY URGE
THE COMMITTEE TO VOTE I. ON SB
ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE AND PLEASE
SEND IT TO THE FULL ASSEMBLY
THANK YOU AND STAY SAFE. THANK
YOU RIDE ONE FIFTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE ONE FIVE FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO. PLEASE
A NEAR SO I HAD. POSITION. CAN
YOU HEAR ME WE CAN HEAR YOU
NAME ORGANIZATION AND POSITION.
I'M SORRY BUT IT APPEARS IN
IDEA I'M FROM CHICAGO ILLINOIS-
REPRESENT ON SUCH A FOR ETHICAL
FINE I'M ASKING NEXT WEEK THE
COURT EACH. O. AND SEVENTY FIVE
IF. THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE
NINETY ONE MINUTE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS ALAN DâN
AND THEN THE PRESIDENT OF
ANIMAL LIONS NETWORK AND ONE
ANGELES AND I'M CALLING FULL OF.
SENATE BILL ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE
IT'S TIME TO STOP THE PILOT
THANK YOU ANIMAL AND OUR STATE.
THANK YOU RIGHT ONE TWENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME CANNELLA AND
THE FOUNDER EXECUTIVE OF
PROJECT. ON BEHALF OF HELP
MEMBERS FOR THE URGE YOU TO
WITH BILL THERE IS NO OTHER
TIME HUMAN THAT OF THE BUT-
THANK YOU RIDE ONE FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
DOMINIQUE MATHIS AND I'M FROM
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA AND I WORK
AT THE ONE ONE SEVEN FIVE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I REMIND
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS SUSAN TURNBULL I LIVE
IN BEACH CALIFORNIA AND I FULLY
SUPPORT AT ONE ONE SEVEN FIVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE BE
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS CALEB THEM I'M CALLING
FROM LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA AND
I STRONG WITH THE CORE SB ONE
ONE SEVEN FIVE. THANK YOU LINE
FORTY EIGHT YEARS AGO I HAD.
MICHAEL IS THAT MAKE. GOOD
MORNING IS I AM I ONE FORTY
EIGHT OR FORTY EIGHT I COULDN'T
HEAR. NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION. MY NAME IS PJ PREMIER
I LIVE IN MARIN COUNTY AND I AM
SUPPORT STRONGLY SB WITH ELEVEN
SEVENTY FIVE AND I WANNA THANK
EVERYONE OKAY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU OF LINE ONE FIFTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HI MY NAME
IS LIANA POLISH CHECK WITH
THEIR NUMBER OF GLENDALE ANIMAL
WHICH THE CALIFORNIA AND I FOR
THE FOR THE SUPPORT SB ONE ONE
SEVEN FIVE THANK YOU PLEASE
MAKE THE RIGHT DECISION I.
THANK YOU EIGHTY FOUR SCORE
HAVE. THE BURNING DOCUMENTS
CALL AND WHAT ABOUT THE ON FOR
THE. FIVE THANK YOU LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS CAROLYN ANGLER
AND CALLING FROM LOS ANGELES
COUNTY AND I FULLY FULLY
SUPPORT BILL AT THE ELEVEN
SEVENTY FIVE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU IN LINE FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
HERE WELCOME IN THE TURNING
PRACTICE BEING LOS ANGELES- THE
TIME TO TALK DEAL PRINCIPLE FOR
STATE REASONS WHAT THE NAME IN
ORDER. IT WAS ISSUE. YEAH WALK
IN A CORRECT IN THE TIME TO
NAPA. BLIND FAITH FIVE PLEASE
GO BACK. COURTNEY THE CAMPAIGN
DIRECT AT OCEANIC PRESERVATION
SOCIETY BASED IN GREEN GRAY
CALIFORNIA WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
SB ONE ONE SEVEN FIVE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RAIMES FORTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS WILLIAM STILL WELL I
LIVE IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND I
THE COURT SB ELEVEN SEVENTY
FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT A ONE TWENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS LINDA
COMBINED I LIVE IN HIGHLAND
PARK CALIFORNIA LOS ANGELES I'M
TOTALLY IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE
ONE SEVEN FIVE OR NOT HIGHLAND
PARK LOS ANGELES LINDA COMBINED.
THANK YOU JUST ONE MOMENT. LINE
ONE THIRTEEN GO AHEAD. BONTA
TOMLINSON I'M WITH PROJECT
HIGHER THE I AM IN. SUPPORT OF
SB ONE ONE SAID FIVE NOBODY
NEEDS TO SHOOT AN ELEPHANT FOR
FIND MY THANK YOU SO IT IS SIX
ONE THING YOU ALL RIGHT THIRTY
GO AHEAD. DID YOU I ONE THIRTY.
YES PLEASE GO AHEAD. WARNER CON
FOUR THOUSAND OAKS CALIFORNIA I
FULLY SUPPORT SB ONE ONE SEVEN
FIVE. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT A ONE
NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS ARLENE MORE DENTAL A
PETER MEMBER FROM LINCOLN
CALIFORNIA AND I FULLY SUPPORT
SB. ONE ONE SEVEN FIVE. THANK
YOU ARE ONE SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO AND CHAVEZ CHICO
CALIFORNIA PETER MEMBER TOTALLY
SUPPORT AT. EIGHT ELEVEN
SEVENTY FIVE. AND PLEASE
PROTECT THE HELP ANIMAL. THANK
YOU LINE FORTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FORTY NINE. YEAH PLEASE
GO AYE AYE NOT THIS IS TRACY
RYMAN THE EXACT I PRESIDENT OF
PEOPLE FOR THE ETHICAL
TREATMENT OF ANIMALS SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF OUR SIX HUNDRED
AND THIRTY THOUSAND MEMBERS AND
SUPPORTERS IN CALIFORNIA AND WE
URGE YOU TO VOTE YES ON AT THE
ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIDE ONE TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
DIANE KANE AND THE PRESIDENT OF
ANIMAL ADVOCATES WORLDWIDE I
URGE YOU TO VOTE I SB. ELEVEN
SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE SEND IT TO
THE FULL EMPLOYEE THANK. THANK
YOU FOR WRITING TO TWENTY FIVE.
I HAVE. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
DALE DREW ONE AND I AM FROM
WALNUT CREEK CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB ONE ONE
SEVEN FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIDE ONE HUNDRED IN NINETEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THIS IS
CHRISTINA MAKING IN PRESIDENT
OF THE OUTCOME PROJECT IN SANTA
BARBARA JOHN RIGHT SB. ELEVEN
THANK YOU RIDE ONE EIGHTY THREE
PLEASE GO I HAD. YEAH LET
CRISTINA CURRENTS FROM ANIMAL
DEFENDERS INTERNATIONAL FROM
OUR LOS ANGELES HEADQUARTERS
FOR A THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORTERS AND OUR TEAM HOLDING
IT DOWN AT OUR WILDLIFE
SANCTUARY INCREASED ITSELF
AFRICA STRONG SUPPORTER THAT
THE ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ROBIN TO THIRTY
FIVE WEEKS AGO I HAD. YES MY
NAME IS JANET RAN IT'S TIME
FROM HOLLOW ALTO CALIFORNIA AND
PLEAD BUT WE DIDN'T FAVORITE
SENATE BILL ELEVEN SEVENTY.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT EIGHTEEN.
PLEASE I HAVE. HI I'M SHAUNA
WALK PICTURE OF NEW BY CAL AND
I'M IN DRUNK THE POOR AT. ONE
ONE SEVEN. THANK YOU RIGHT
AWAY. AND ASKED WE GO AHEAD.
LINE ONE SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME'S EILEEN ALIGNMENT
GOING TO COOK THE MEXICO
INDIVIDUAL ORDERED AS ONE ONE
SEVEN FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RYAN TO NINETEEN GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS FOR CARL AFTER. ON
THE CITIZENS PLEASE PASS SB ONE
ONE SEVEN FIVE STATE YOU. THANK
YOU IT RIGHT SIX SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS YELLOW
AND I'M FROM POP CALIFORNIA WE
FULLY SUPPORT CENTER BILL THE
SEVENTY FIVE THE BRIEF WE THAT
GONNA GIVE. EMPATHY OF BELIEVE
ANIMAL. THANK YOU ARE LYING TO
THIRD NINE PLEASE GO. HI THIS
IS DOROTHY IN CALABASAS
CALIFORNIA I URGE YOU TO PASS
SENATE BILL A LOT SEVENTY FIVE
IF NOT NOW WHEN. THANK YOU OF
LINE THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD ELAINE LIVE SEE COUNCIL
FROM WHAT LA SAN A PRIVATE TO.
IN ROBUST SUPPORT OF SB. ONE
SEVEN. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT TO
THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS THE ROAD GREENBERG FROM
CINEMA CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF
SB. ONE ONE SEVEN FIVE. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT ONE THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO I HAVE. HI MY NAME IS
BEA ACOSTA FROM MAYES CAN AN
EXTRA POOR AND ONE MORE SEVEN.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ARE RIGHT
OR ONE EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO I
HAD. MY NAME IS BRENDA WILSON
FROM VENTURA CALIFORNIA CALLING
ON BEHALF OF SOCIAL COMPASSION
IN LEAD THIS. AND I STRONG
SUPPORT ELEVEN KEVIN FIVE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU A LINE TWO
ONE TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS TRACY CHILD. THIS IS
TRACY CHILD INCENDIO DIRECTOR
OF PLANT YEAH I GO AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB. ONE ONE
SEVEN FIVE. THANK YOU A LINE TO
FORTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD AT. HI
MY NAME IS TRAILER LANDAU I'M A
POLICE OFFICER THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES SPEAKING ON MY OWN
BEHALF. AND PRESIDENT OF
STARFISH ANIMAL RESCUE I AM
CALLING IN IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AT ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU BLACK AND WON
ALLFOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS LYNETTE CRANE I WORK
WITH FELINE NETWORK OF THE
CENTRAL COAST A LOCAL NON
PROFIT HUMANE ORGANIZATION IN
SAN LUIS OBISPO CALIFORNIA AND
I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT OF SB
ONE ONE SEVEN FIVE PLEASE DO
THE RIGHT THING THANK YOU. LINE
EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HOLIDAY VAN HERE AND I'M
CALLING FROM PASSAGE AND AN
INDIVIDUAL DOCTOR PORTER THIS
IT SEVEN FIVE WHICH THROUGH THE
PATH TO THANK YOU. THE YOU JUST
WANT TO READ YOU OF BACK WE
HAVE HUNDRED AND FIFTY PEOPLE
IN THE QUEUE- SO PLEASE NAME
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RAIMES
SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THANK YOU MY NAME IS
JENNIFER MERCY AND THE LA CITY
EMPLOYEE CALLING ON MY OWN
BEHALF AND FORMER CHANNEL
ISLANDS ARCHAEOLOGIST AND PS
DOES SINCE I SUPPORT SB ONE ONE
SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT ONE THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS MORNING SOLOMON IN
NORTH HOLLYWOOD I'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH ANIMALS SUPPORTING
THEM FOR OVER SIXTY YEARS
PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL WE
DON'T WANT TO BE AS BAD AS
CHINA AND WE HAVE TO WORK THAT
THIS BLOOD LUST SUPPORT THIS
BILL PLEASE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU RYAN ONE FORTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS DANIEL
CAP CALLING FROM SAN DIEGO
CALIFORNIA AND I URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY FIVE THANK YOU. THEY DO
A LINE THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. PRIME MINISTER SMALL
BURNHAM A REGISTERED VOTER IN
SANTA BARBARA CALIFORNIA I'M
CALLING TO VOICE MY SUPPORT
PRESS BE ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE IF
ANY OF THESE ANIMALS PROTECT IN
THIS BILL COULD SPEAK IN THE
NAME DOLLARS COMBINED. NINETY
EIGHT ONE NINETY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS A BELLETTI
FROM LOS. CALIFORNIA RENTS
STRONGLY URGING COMMITTEE
DEVELOP YEAH. ON F. E. ONE
SEVEN FIVE THANK YOU THANK.
THANK YOU RIDE ONE AND ELEVEN
PLEASE AHEAD. LINE ONE ONE ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LINE ONE FIVE
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
THE TUTORIAL ITEM A PHD FROM
STUDIO CITY CALIFORNIA I FULLY
SUPPORT THE PASSAGE OF SB ONE
ONE SEVEN FIVE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I'M SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TRANSOCEAN KEEN WE LIVE IN LOS
ANGELES CALIFORNIA AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT SENATE BILL
ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE. YEAH.
THANK YOU RIDE ONE TWENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO ARE AT. HELLO MY NAME
IS THE BILL SINGER AND I'M
CALLING FROM ANTHONY TO
CALIFORNIA AND I'M CALLING
DEVOID MY FULL SUPPORT FOR AT
BE. ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE. LINE
ONE THIRTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S FOR
CHASE TO DO. AND I'M CALLING
FROM SINGER CALIFORNIA AND I
SUPPORT SB ONE ONE SEVEN FIVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I FIFTY
ONE WOULD PLEASE GO I HAD. MY
NAME IS GENET FOSTER FROM
PASADENA CALIFORNIA I'M CALLING
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE S. B.
ONE ONE SEVEN FIVE CALIFORNIA
MUST DO ITS PART TO PRESERVE
AND DATE. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
ONE THE SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS HOLLY SILENCE
AND I'M READY TO LOOK UNDER AND
THE CORE OF THE BE ONE ONE PLUS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT ONE
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI NAME
IS BRETT ASHLEY WHAT THE CA AND
I FULLY SUPPORT. SB SEVENTY
FIVE THANK YOU. Q. RIGHT SEVEN
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IT CAN REALLY
THOMPSON. RESIDENT AS
SACRAMENTO I STRONGLY. SENATE
BILL ONE ONE SEVEN FIVE PLEASE
HELP ARM AND THE SAN LANE.
THANK YOU RAIMES SIXTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS
SUSAN IRVINE I AM A MEMBER OF
THE PEOPLE OF ETHICAL TREATMENT
OF ANIMALS AND I AM FULLY IN
SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN SEVENTY
FIVE AGAIN CHICO CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU RIDE ONE SEVENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. CAROL
GAUGE HECTOR HILL ANIMAL
SANCTUARY IN NEW CASTLE
CALIFORNIA WE SUPPORT SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY FIVE. THANK YOU REID
FORTY SEVEN PLEASE OR HAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS ON TWITTER CAN
YOU COUNT NINETY AT THE PARK SB
ONE ONE SEVEN FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU A LINE THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS GEORGIA MONO JONES AND I
FULLY SUPPORT SB ONE ONE
SEVENTY FIVE. I'M FROM SANTA
MONICA CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU
RYAN ONE FORTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS ALEXANDRA MORE. I AM ALSO
FROM SANTA MONICA CALIFORNIA
AND I AM CALLING IN FULL
SUPPORT OF SB ONE ONE SEVEN
FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
DON'T WANT TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LINE ONE ZERO TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AND ONE FOURTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS JOHN HART-
I MET BURBANK CALIFORNIA AND
THEN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE THINK SO
MUCH. TWO HUNDRED PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS JOHN
RATE CATTLE I'M CALLING FROM
LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA WHAT
FULL SUPPORT FOR ACT BE ELEVEN
SEVENTY FIVE THANK YOU. LINE
ONE SIXTEEN PLEASE GO OUT AT.
HI MY NAME IS ALLISON MORE
KALRA BERNARD CALLING FROM
BURLINGAME CALIFORNIA I'M THE
ONE I'VE UC DAVIS TEACHING AT
THE SAME GRADUATE STUDENT AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF VICTORIA AND
I'M IN FULL SUPPORT OF SB ONE
ONE SEVEN FIVE. THANK YOU.
LYING TO YOU I HAD. LINE ONE
THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE ONE THREE NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WHY DON'T AND HAVE BEEN
BEAT. ADD SHE. WHAT WAS THE-
WORLDWIDE ONE. WE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS MELANIE MORE RARE
I'M CALLING FROM THE VALLEY
CALIFORNIA- AND I WOULD URGE
YOU TO PLEASE THE COURT BILL AT
B. ONE ONE SEVEN FIVE THANK YOU
SO MUCH. LINE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS LAUREN MAY QUE I'M
FROM PACIFIC PALISADES
CALIFORNIA I'M IN FAVOR- BUT-
AND URGE YOU TO WILL ALSO VOTE
FOR AT THREE ELEVEN SEVENTY
FIVE DUE TO PUBLIC HEALTH
ISSUES AND OUR ECONOMY RIGHT
NOW IN CALIFORNIA HELLO THE
BIODIVERSITY THAT IF. LINE ONE
EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS ASHLEY PAGE I'M CALLING
FROM LOS ANGELES COUNTY IN
SUPPORT OF SB ONE ONE SEVENTY
FIVE AND THE WHAT MARKET. THANK
YOU. LINE SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LINE SIX ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO PAGE PARKING
THROUGH. WESTLAKE VILLAGE
CALIFORNIA. I AM IN SUPPORT OF
THE ONE ONE SEVEN FIVE IN WHICH
A NINETEEN NEWS NETWORK. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT A ONE TWENTY NINE
THESE GO I HAD. I AM SEVENTY
NINE THE STORE HAS. HI THIS IS
LEE FALLOW IT'S THOMPSON IN
TAHOE THIS TO CALIFORNIA'S
SPEAKING AS AN INDIVIDUAL AND
FOR THE ANIMALS TARGETED THAT
DO NOT HAVE A VOICE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB. ONE ONE SEVEN
FIVE ENERGY TO DO THE SAME
THANK YOU. LINE SIXTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
JONATHAN MARTINEZ I'M FROM
MIAMI FLORIDA AS AN INDIVIDUAL
AND I FULLY SUPPORT SB. ELEVEN
SEVENTY FIVE. BUT TWENTY EIGHT
THREE FOUR HAD. HELLO NAY HAD
ORGANIZATION A POSITION. DID
YOU THIRTY TWO EIGHT STATE YOUR
NAME ORGANIZATION A POSITION.
AB MIND MY NAME IS WENDY
BRAMBLE I AM REPRESENTING THE
STATE MOVEMENT IN DEFENSE OF
ANIMALS AND DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE AND IT'S WRONG
SUPPORT SB ONE ONE SEVEN FIVE.
LINE SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO I
HAD. HI MY NAME IS ROBERT
MICKEY FROM LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AT THE ONE ONE SEVEN
FIVE IT'S REALLY A NO BRAINER.
BY FIFTY PLEASE GO I HAVE. ONE
FIFTY. LEAVE TE CAR WAS IN
THOUSAND OAKS CALIFORNIA WE HAD
SIX PEOPLE ON THE LINE I NUMBER
ONE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SENATOR LEVIN SEVENTY FIVE NEXT
THANK YOU ERIC BIGELOW CALLING
FROM WHAT. LINE TWO ELEVEN
PLEASE GO I HAD. TWO ELEVEN
HERE SUSAN HARGREAVES THE
FOUNDER OF ANIMAL HERO KID IN
FULL SUPPORT OF NOT KILLING
ANIMALS AND ALL OF OUR ANIMALS
ZERO KIDS. THANK YOU RYAN TO
FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE
FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS CAN GEREN I LIVE IN
HERMOSA BEACH CALIFORNIA I'M
CALLING IN FULL SUPPORT AND AT
ELEVEN SEVEN FIVE THANK YOU.
YOU. THANK YOU REID FORTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
JANE VELEZ MITCHELL I'M A
JOURNALIST AUTHOR AND PRESIDENT
OF THE JANE AND JANE NEWS
NETWORK CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO
LEAD THE WAY YEAH I BE ELEVEN
SEVENTY FIVE. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT SIXTY EIGHT NO I HAD.
THAT REPRESENTING PROJECT HI
JOHN OR AT AGE ELEVEN SEVENTY
EIGHT YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
TWO FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO I
HAVE. LINE TWO FIFTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE TWO FIVE
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. LYING TO
SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME'S CHRIS MARTIN I'M AN
INVESTMENT BANKER VENTURE
CAPITALISTS ON BEHALF OF LA
FINANCIAL TECHNOLOGY COMMUNITY
I SUPPORT AT THE ONE ONE SEVEN
FIVE. THANK YOU. LYING TO SET
AN. LINE TWO FOUR NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. LINE TWO FORTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MANY
MYSTERIOUS LAWSON NUMBER THAT A
LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA AND I
URGE THE ASSEMBLY TO SUPPORT
SENATE BILL ONE ONE SEVEN FIVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT ONE
TO THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO I HAD.
YES MY BY. I REMINDED YOU
SHOULD WANT IT BACK THEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS LINDA
HACKETT I'M A RESIDENT OF LOS
ANGELES CALIFORNIA AND I'M
CALLING WITH MY STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB. ONE ONE. IT'S A ONE ONE
SEVEN FIVE THIRTY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU A LINE TO NINETY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS RATHER
SOLO SEGMENT CALIFORNIA INTO
COURT. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT TWO
SIXTY THREE YEARS AGO I HAD. HI
THIS IS A LIMITED HELP ON-
CHICAGO ILLINOIS I AM IN SCHOOL
SUPPORT AT THE ELEVEN SEVENTY
FIVE I REALLY EXPECT THE
COMMITTEE TO DO TAKING. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT- NINETY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WELL THAT IS
VERY BIGELOW I'M A CONCERNED
CITIZEN AND LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA THE SUPPORT. AT ONE
ONE SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RYAN TO NINETY NINE PLEASE
AHEAD. YES THIS IS SIMONE RARE-
SOCIAL COMPASSION LEGISLATION
BY PUTTING A COMMUNICATIONS AND
STOCK SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND I HAVE NO FURTHER
RIGHTS IN QUEUE AT THAT TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL
MOVE ON NOW TO. THE OPPOSITION
WITNESSES WE HAVE TWO WITNESSES
EACH WILL HAVE TWO MINUTES- AND
WILL ASK THE FIRST ONE COULD
PLEASE STEP FORWARD. BELIEVE
THE WITNESSES ARE CALLING IN
MODERATOR SO WE CAN GET THEM IN
THE QUEUE. LEAVE THE THOUGHT
WHAT BLINDS ARE OPEN. FIRST
WITNESSES MAXI PIA. HI GOOD
EVENING- MY NAME IS MAX THE PLO
YOU. AND I'M FOUR NINE MEDIA
WORKING FINE AND YOU'LL CALL
NOT SO WITH THE PART THAT I'M
EIGHTY SIX CONSERVATION OUR
YEAH. ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTY SIX
GRAY KIT THREE HOW THOUSAND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS MEDIA INC THE
SEVENTY FOR UP. IT IS THE THIRD
AFRICAN TIME THAT THE INCLUDE
THE BOTTOM LINE GOING. WE HAVE
THE WAR I. THREE WILL BE BY
WITHOUT BOX BUT- THE OTHER KEEP
THE A LIE AND. THE OF NOT MAYBE
ON HUNTING. I BY LOCAL
COMMITTED FOR. THAT IS ON NEW
PRODUCTS YOU WILL OUT LIKE SO
FAR LOCAL PRODUCTION AND WHITE
PLAID MAYBE OUT. IT WILL NOT A
NEW COMMUNITY BENEFIT FROM
WELCOME TO THE EXTENT HUNTING
THEY ALSO DO THAT THE OTHER OF
PEOPLE FROM. ONE OF THE- IT'S
UP TO HAVE ENOUGH FOR GOT AND
BASICALLY I THINK BY THAT I DUE
TO CHANGE WHAT I'D LIKE
COMPLETELY FINISHED THE ONE OF
THE BILLION AND THAT BIG WHO
HAVE THAT KIND OF THE BIBLE
MEDIA PEOPLE THAT FIFTH THE
VALUE. WE HAVE NO. WHY NOT
BECAUSE THEY DON'T KNOW I WOULD
LIKE IT'S DEFINITIVE LISTEN TO
THE VOICE OF. ONE LIVE. YEAH
WITHIN THE AYE WE NEED TO YOU
NEED ALL THE ROOMS WE HAVE A
CHOI THANK YOU MUCH. THANK YOU
FOR NEXT WITNESS GEORGE ON
GETTING. TWO MINUTES. CHAD
MENDES BY CHAIRMAN DANIEL AND
ONE OR MORE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ALLOW ME TO DISPEL
INDEED IMPORTANT LET AND ONE
ONE SEVEN FIVE MY NAME IS
GEORGE BANG PT I WOULD BE IN
THE OF FACT WILDLIFE WILL
THIRTY TWO THINGS NINE EIGHTY
TWO ENDING IS CHAIRMAN OF THE
BOARD OF PROVIDING THE DEFENSE
MANAGEMENT INTO ADMINISTRATIVE
DIVISIONS OVER THAT BOOK I AB
SEVENTY MANY CONTACTING
SOUTHERN AFRICA I'VE
REPRESENTED NEEDING PUBLIC
GOVERNMENT AT ALL THANK YOU
MEETING. FROM THE FOURTH
CONFERENCE OVER THE BACK IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE IN BOTH
CHINA TO THE EIGHTEENTH
CORPORATE IN SWAZILAND IN TWIN
INDUSTRY FELL AND IN TWENTY
NINETEEN. WILL THE DEALS THAT
SAYS I'VE BEEN ON THE PUBLIC
TELEVISION TIME EXPLAINING WHY
THESE PROPOSED LEGISLATION IS
DETRIMENTAL TO THE CONSERVATION
INFECTING THE BILL MANAGEMENT
AWKWARD LIVE IN MY COUNTRY IN
THE REGION AS A WHOLE SEC
TRAINABLE HUNTING IN ZIMBABWE
THE SCIENTIFIC EARLY MANAGED.
IT TAKES PLACE IN THE AREA OF
GUYS THEY DID FOR. THANK YOU. I
YOUR ANIMALS IN THIRTY THAT
COULD BE DONE. TO DETERMINE THE
BOOK DEBT THAT THE EACH. AREA
HUNTING THAT ANNUAL WITH BY. OF
ALL THEY CALL. CHAIRED BY WORD
LIKE WILL THOUGHT COULD. IS
THAT TAKES PLACE. THE RECORD
THAT. TO DETERMINE IN COFFEE
POT. SUCH INFORMATION IS USEFUL-IN. FOR DETERMINING FACT
FIFTEEN NINETY DECISION. IF THE
CONCLUSION OF THE HON THE
TROPHY THAT TAKE INTO THE TEXT
DENNIS FOR TREATMENT AND
INSPECT. BEFORE EXPORT TIM IS I
EASY TO INSURE THAT THERE ARE
NO DO YOU IS X. REVENUE MY
HUNTING ON THE LAND ARE YOU THE
TO C<c.cyan> THE VISION PROGRAM.</c>
AND IDEAS SAY. FOR THE WORD LIE
I DO SEE. IT ORTEZ. DAYS TWENTY
COMMUNITY WITH THE IT'S
CRESCENTA LAKE. JAMES THAT
THERE IS PLANTS WITH THIS TO
THE RECKLESS. BEING GAINES AT
SPEEDS. OVER THE U. S. AND
BELOW OF THE BY WILLIGIS.
GOVERNING TROPHY HUNTING. MY
PLEA. IS THAT RIGHT TO BE A BIG
LAKE. SHOULD NOT PACKED TO
RIVER WILL WORLD MY PRACTICES
INDEPENDENCE THAT THEY'VE BEEN
THAT DESTROY FIVE IT GREAT CORD
TO OUR WILL COME I THINK YOU.
THANK YOU MUCH UNTIL WE HAVE
APPROX A HUNDRED PLUS PEOPLE IN
THE QUEUE- MODERATOR IF YOU GET
THEM READY TO GO. FOR A
PROVIDING OF TELEPHONE.
OPPOSITION POSITION SO AT THIS
TIME WILL ASK IF THERE'S ANYONE
IN THE- CHAMBER- THAT WILL BE
TESTIFYING. IN OPPOSITION OR
NAME ORGANIZATION AND POSITION
PLEASE OPPOSITION IN A ROW.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MY NAME
IS BILL GAINES AND I'M HERE
TODAY REPRESENTING SEVERAL
DIFFERENT NON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS ROCKY MOUNTAIN
ELK FOUNDATION CALIFORNIA DEAR
ASSOCIATION THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THE WILD SHEEP
FOUNDATION CALIFORNIA HOUSER
FOR CONSERVATION THE CAL OR
WETLANDS AND WATERFOWL COUNCIL
CLERY BASE WELL ON DISSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA BOWMAN UNDER STATE
ARCHERY ASSOCIATION SAN DIEGO
COUNTY WILDLIFE FEDERATION THE
SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA CHAPTER
OF. SOME PART OF INTERNATIONAL
AND THE BLACK FRANK GROUP WE
JOINED SEVERAL AFRICAN NATIONS
IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO THE
AFRICAN SPECIES PROVISIONS OF
THIS BILL WE ARE NEUTRAL ON THE
REST THAT PORTION OF THE BILL
CONTAINS ALL THE CONTROVERSY
ALL THE LEGAL ISSUES AND ALL
THE OPPOSITION AND WE URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO RECOMMEND THAT
PROVISION PEOPLE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- SEEN
THAT THERE ISN'T ANYONE ELSE IN
THE ROOM I'M ASKING IF THERE IS
ANYONE AT THE REMOTE STATIONS
PREPARE TO. PROVIDE THEIR NAME
ORGANIZATION IN OPPOSITION
POSITION. ANYONE AT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATIONS- PREPARED TO
STATE THEIR NAME ORGANIZATION
AND OPPOSITION. OKAY HEARING
THAT THERE ISN'T ANYONE- THERE
WE WILL MOVE ON. A MODERATOR TO
THE- PHONE CALLS AND THE WILL
REMIND EVERYONE THAT- WE'RE
ASKING FOR THEIR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION AND I
BELIEVE WE HAVE- OVER A HUNDRED
FOLKS THAT MIGHT BE. IN LINE TO
OUR CALL IN WE WANT TO INSTRUCT
FOLKS THAT WANT TO CALL IN IF
YOU PLEASE HANG UP SO THAT
OTHERS CAN CALL IN AND TO BE IN
THE QUEUE AS WELL THANK YOU.
MODERATOR TIMES YOURS THANK YOU
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. IT WILL
PROVIDE ONE TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES THIS IS BEING
READ WITH THE NATIONAL RIFLE
ASSOCIATION ALSO HERE PROGRAM
TO CALIFORNIA TODAY IN STRONG
OPPOSITION THAT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LINE ONE SIXTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS
EVENING ON BEHALF OF THE
CONGRESSIONAL. ASIAN AND STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN PROTECTION ACT THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT THREE SIXTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD HELLO- MY NAME IS LAURA
I'M A NUMBER PETER I'M CALLING
FROM BERKELEY CALIFORNIA AND I
MET FOR A SENATE BILL. ELEVEN
SEVENTY FIVE WHICH WOULD BAN
THE POSSESSION OF BODY PARTS
FROM THE ELEPHANT LINES AND
OTHER. ANIMAL IF YOU WERE LINE
ONE NINETY TWO PLEASE GO I HAD.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I KEVIN TO DRAW THE
REPRESENTING- P. JACK. THE
NATIONAL TRADE ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING THE RETAIL RETAIL
PET TRADE- THE AMENDMENTS- THAT
A PROPOSED IN THE MEASURE I AM
ANALYSIS ORGANIZATION A
POSITION. YES I WE HAD OPPOSE
POSITION IN LOOKS LIKE WE'RE
GETTING CLOSER TO RESOLVING THE
ISSUES THAT WE HAD WITH THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU A
LINE ONE NINETY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MY NAME IS
MICHAEL AND WITH THE NATIONAL
SHOOTING SPORTS FOUNDATION I'M
HERE TO EXPLAIN OPPOSITION OF
SENATE BILL ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
REID FORTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS DAVE CASTROL
I AM THE PRESIDENT OF THE LOS
ANGELES CHAPTER SPORT CLUB
INTERNATIONAL ON BEHALF OF OUR
LOCAL STATE NATIONAL AND
INTERNATIONAL MEMBERSHIP WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE
PATERNALISTIC IN COLONIAL A
STICK SB. ONE SEVEN FIVE. THANK
YOU I'M TWO EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO I HAD. YOUR MEMBERS HERE WE
WENT WITH CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE MOTION PICTURE ASSOCIATION
OF AMERICA WE DON'T HAVE A
POSITION BUT ARE URGING THE
AUTHOR IN THE COMMITTEE TO
CONSIDER EXEMPTING THE FILM AND
TELEVISION. INDUSTRY OUT OF THE
BILL FOR THE POTENTIAL
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES AS IT
RELATES TO THE IMPORTATION FOR
COMMERCIAL PURPOSES OF ALIVE
AND DEAD ANIMALS AND WITH THAT-
GERMAN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RYAN ONE EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS SUSAN HAYES HIDDEN
HILLS CALIFORNIA FORMULA A
MEMBER OF THE SPARK OF
INTERNATIONAL AND IS A LACK OF
SCIENTIFIC BASIS TO ENACT THIS
BILL I STRONGLY AND VEHEMENTLY
OPPOSE SB ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE.
LINE ONE THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. PLEASE THE MAC MINI FROM
HUNTINGTON BEACH I'M THE CO
CHAIR OF THE PARK CLUB
INTERNATIONAL CALIFORNIA
COALITION AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BOB PROPOSITION.
LYING TO NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES HI THIS IS DOCTOR
RUSSELL KELLY I AM A STRONG-
JUST PERSONAL- WE AGAINST THAT
SB- ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE I THINK
IT'S UNFAIR TO AFRICAN NATIONS
THANK YOU. WHY IN TWO THIRTY
SIX PLEASE SO I HAVE. BRETT
HANSEN AND SUNLAND CALIFORNIA
OPPOSE. ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE.
LINE TWO FORTY THREE FOUR YEARS
AGO I HAVE. HELLO MY NAME IS
MICHELLE BALLET ON AND I'M A
MEMBER OF THE AND I'M CALLING I
THANK BOTH FELL GEORGE WILLIS
QUESTION HAVE YOU HAD A FRAZIER
BOB TRANSPORTING. TROPHY IT IS.
RAIMES THREE PLEASE GO I HAD.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS KENNETH
PACETTI I'M A SACRAMENTO SAFARI
CLUB BOARD MEMBER I LIVE IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
SENATE BILL ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE
THANK YOU. LINE ONE EIGHTY
EIGHT WE STILL HAVE. TERRY
BRENNAN FROM THE SAN DIEGO
COUNTY WILDLIFE FEDERATION ALSO
REPRESENTING SAN DIEGO ZOO
SAFARI CLUB INTERNATIONAL
CHAPTER OF MINIMALLY OPPOSED TO
SB. ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE AFRICAN
LIVES MATTER THANK YOU. LINE
ONE FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS COREY MASON CERTIFIED
WILDLIFE BIOLOGIST AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR BALLOT OR
CLUB. BECAUSE OF THE COMPLETE
LACK OF ENGAGEMENT AND
COMMUNICATION WITH AFRICAN
WALLACH MINISTRIES TO
UNDERSTAND THE NEGATIVE IMPACT
THANK YOU LAKE LAPPED AT NEW
YORKERS ATION OF POSITION
PLEASE. LINE TWO SIXTY THREE
PLEASE CALL HAVE. HI THIS IS
MARK HENLEY WITH CALIFORNIA
WATER COST ASSOCIATION AND
WE'RE IN STRONG AFTER
OPPOSITION TO THE AFRICAN GAME
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ARE RIGHT TO ALL
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. DON
GOTTEN ANY PRESIDENT SACRAMENTO
SAFARI CLUB AND CO CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION OF S. CI
BUT WE STRONGLY OPPOSE. ELEVEN
SEVENTY FIVE. LINE TWO
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION PLEASE HAVEN'T. YES MY
NAME IS WILL THEY KNOW NOW AND
I RIVER THAT MYSELF AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
LYING TO NINETY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS MATT MCCLOSKEY
ACOSTA INCORPORATED PRESIDENT
IN SAN CLEMENTE CALIFORNIA AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE SB ONE ONE
SEVEN FIVE. THANK YOU LINE ONE
EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS GERRY
CARNOT JUNIOR I'M A RETIRED
CALIFORNIA WARDEN FORMER
PRESIDENT AND FORMER
LEGISLATIVE LIAISON FOR THE
CALIFORNIA FISH AND GAME WITH A
SEARCH ENGINE I OPPOSE SB
ELEVEN SEVEN FIVE. IT FURTHER
SIGNIFICANTLY STRETCH DENIM
HELP. LINE THREE ZERO SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES JENNIFER
THOMAN FROM NEWPORT BEACH
CALIFORNIA I'M STRONGLY OPPOSE
SB ONE MONTH THAT. LINE NINETY
EIGHT SO I HAVE. LINE THREE
EIGHTEEN. LINE THREE EIGHTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY ONE TWENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. JULIE
WALTERS FOR MORE ON THE
CALIFORNIA I THOUGHT EARLIER
BUT ON THE COURT. I AM THREE
TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
THIS IS ALICE WALKER I AM AN
ACTRESS VETERAN ACTOR THIRTY
YEARS AND MY HUSBAND JOHN
LANDGRAF HEAD OF THAT FACT. NOW
AT DISNEY AND WE ARE PETER
SUPPORTERS AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THANK BILL. LINE THIRTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
TRAINER AND COMPASSION BAY AND
THE BAY AREA CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT. LINE THREE THIRTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I CAN
CONCRETE BUT AS CALIFORNIA TO
SUPPORT SB ONE ONE SEVEN FIVE.
LINE THREE HUNDRED PLEASE SO I
HAD. HI MY NAME IS AMY JACOBSON
FROM LOS ANGELES AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE.
THANK YOU AND OVER TO LINE ONE
THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH I'M JUST WONDERING HOW
COME THAT THEY CAN CONTINUE TO
MILLION AMERICANIZATION
POSITION. LINE THREE THIRTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MEANING
YOU CAN JUMP ON THE RESIDENTS
OF LOS ANGELES UNFORTUNATELY
WERE CUT OFF BEFORE BUT I MEAN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THAT THE ONE
ONE SEVEN FIVE THANK YOU.
FLIGHT NINETY EIGHT WE DON'T
HAVE. I HAVE NO FURTHER LINE
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. OUR MODERATOR.
NIXON JOB WE HAVE NOW THE BILL
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE MASKING-
THIS COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER THE
RECOMMENDATION WHICH IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED WITH THE LIMITS
BEING ACCEPTED BY THE AUTHOR
THE AUTHOR IS- IN- THE QUEUE TO
ANSWER ANY DIRECT QUESTIONS
ADDRESS ANY COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS IT MAY BE REYES AT.
I'M OPENED UP FOR QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. WE HAVE
SOME REMEMBER RUBIO. THANK YOU
I'M SENATOR STERN I HAVE BEEN
CONTACTED BY COLLEAGUES WHO
HAVE SMALLER TO A LOGICAL-
ORGANIZATIONS IN THEIR
DISTRICTS AND NEAR MINE THEY
HAVE RAISED CONCERNS THAT
SMALLER SIZES WOULD BE SEVERELY
IMPACTED BY THIS BILL AND WHAT
CAUSES THEM TO CLOSE WOULD YOU
BE ABLE TO ELABORATE ON HOW YOU
PLAN TO ADDRESS THIS CONCERN
FROM WHAT I UNDERSTAND YOU WILL
HAVE ALREADY HAD A
CONVERSATION- WITH SEVERAL
COLLEAGUES THAT I'M REFERRING
TO AND- THE INFORMATION WAS NOT
CLEAR IF YOU CAN ELABORATE I
WOULD APPRECIATE IT. SO WELL.
THE OFFICE IT'S FOR THE AUTHOR
WELL THIS SISTER GETS IN THE
QUEUE WILL HAVE THE PRESENTER
UP TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE-
POINTS THAT YOU VOICE. PLEASE
GO AHEAD THANK YOU. IF YOU CAN
ANSWER THEM IF NOT I WILL WAIT
FOR I BELIEVE MISTER- COMING TO
IS HOPEFULLY A STILL ON THEIR
AVAILABLE. THE AUTHORS
AVAILABLE CALL. THE OTTERS
AVAILABLE THAT PLEASE CLOSE
YOUR. YEAH I'M I'M SORRY DID
YOU WANT ME TO RESPOND TO A
PARTICULAR QUESTION OR TO GIVE
FINAL STATE HERE. SENATOR STERN
THIS IS SOMEONE NUMBER REVIEW I
JUST WANTED TO- ASK I HAVE BEEN
CONTACTED BY A COLLEAGUES WHO
HAVE SMALLER TO A LOGICAL
ORGANIZATIONS IN THEIR
DISTRICTS AND YOUR MIND THEY
HAVE RAISED CONCERNS AND OTHERS
WHOSE WHAT BE SEVERELY IMPACTED
BY THIS BILL AND WHAT CARDS
CLOSE. TO BE ABLE TO LAND ON
YOUR MANAGER THESE. COME WHAT
YOU ALREADY THEIR ISSUES NOT
ADDRESS YES THANK YOU FOR
MEMBER FOR THAT AND IT FOR THAT
NEEDING CLEAR THERE- SO. WE
HAVE TALKED TO SOME SMALLER
ZOOS WHO EXPRESSED CONCERNS
THAT PERHAPS- BECAUSE OF THE
BILL'S PROHIBITION ON
IMPORTATION OF ANIMALS OF
WILDLIFE THAT HAVE POTENTIAL
RISK OF DO NOT A TRANSMISSION.
THAT THAT WOULD BE INTERPRETED
TO BROADLY BASED INHIBIT THEM
FROM IMPORTING SAY NEW SPECIES-
TO SOUTH AFRICAN DEAR DIE WE
HEARD ABOUT- IN IT IN A TWO AND
A SMALL DO AND THEY WILL BE
IMPORTANT TO MORE- SOUTH
AMERICAN WILD DEER INTO THEIR
PARK. KEEP THAT ATTRACTION
GOING WHAT WE WHAT WE SAID IS
THAT- WE HAVE. WE'RE NOT
PLANNING TO OF PUT ON OUT OR
PLAY BAN ON THAT ON HOW. WHILE
BEING A BUT THAT WE DO. FOR ALL
SPECIES A RIGOROUS- A RIGOROUS
FILTER FOR ANY POTENTIAL DO NOT
A TRANSMISSION RATES SO WE'VE
BEEN TRYING TO HONE IN ON THE
LANGUAGE IF YOU LOOK AT. I'M A
POINT TO THE RIGHT SECTION THE
BILL HERE BUT IF THE SECTION
ABOUT- HOW A NOVEL BY RISK IS.
IS DEFINED AND ALSO HOW THAT
THAT THE DFW WITH THE AUTHORITY
IS IMPOSED WE STILL WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT- POTENTIALLY
SICK- HIGH RISK ANIMALS OF ANY
KIND WE DON'T KNOW WHERE MAY
COME FROM MAYBE AB IN.
MAMMALIAN COULD BE REPTILIAN
WE'VE GOT TO BE A LITTLE BIT
BROAD THERE BECAUSE WE JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
NOT BRINGING IN. A NEW VIRUS
EVER. THAT CAN'T HAPPEN SO WE
WERE HOPING THAT THE SMALL THIS
CONCERTED STICK WITH THAT ON
THAT FILTER BUT KNOW THAT
THERE'S NO INTENT IN THIS
LEGISLATION TO CUT OFF- TING
TRADE. IT IN SORT OF ANY. WAY
HERE BUT I HOPE THAT THEY ALSO
YOU KNOW THEY MAYFACE
PERMITTING CHALLENGES
THEMSELVES BY THE WAY IN TERMS
OF. IMPORTING THOSE THOSE FEW
ANIMAL THAT THEY NEED HEY RICK
THE SUPPLY. BUT THE BILL
DOESN'T REALLY SPEAK TO THOSE
REGULATIONS AT ALL SO I KNOW
THERE'S BEEN A DISTINCT
TENSIONS WITH DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WHAT. AND ALL THE- BUT
I. DECIDED TO TRY TO READ ALL
OF THAT HERE IN THE LATEST SO.
THAT THAT'S MY TAKE ON THE
MATTER I I'M HAPPY TO CHILL
DOWN TRENT PULL UP THE RIGHT
PART OF THE BILL HERE TO OF
THAT HELPS. YES IF I MAY
RESPOND THANK YOU. SENATOR
STERN HOWEVER I'VE BEEN IN THIS
BUSINESS NOW FOR FORTY YEARS
AND YOU KNOW OUR INTENTIONS- IF
NOT WRITTEN IN THE BILL. CAN BE
INTERPRETED BY ANY DEPARTMENT
AS THEY SEE FIT AND SO IF THERE
IS NO SPECIFIC. YOU KNOW.
OUTLINE OR- REFERENCE TO HOW
WE'RE GOING TO HELP BILL SMALL
WHOSE BAND THAT'S NOT GOING TO
HAPPEN AND YOU YOU KNOW THAT
VERY WELL. AND SO I'M LOOKING
YOU KNOW I UNDERSTAND I WOULD
POINT YOU TO THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS. COULD BE HELPFUL
GUIDE IF YOU PUT TO I THINK
IT'S THE SECOND THE LAST PAGE
IT LESTAT THE FOUR CORE AREAS
AMENDMENT TAKEN IN THE
LEGISLATION- SUBSTANTIAL
PORTION WHICH WERE DESIGNED TO
ALLEVIATE THOSE CONCERNS ABOUT
A HAVING A VAGUE DEFINITION.
OVERLY BROAD CRITERIA THE KIND
OF WOULD MAKE MY WORDS HOLLOW
WHEN I SAY MY INTENT NOT TO.
WITH THEY'RE DOING ON A DAY. SO
THAT I MEAN DID YOU GIVE YOU
LIPS THE I CAN THE COMMITTEE
DID A REGULAR JOB ON THAT POINT
AND I I'M I'M HAPPY TO TALK
THREE EVEN IF THERE'S TESTIMONY
OR ANYONE AROUND WHO HAS THAT
WHO REPRESENTS A SMALL THESE
HOW THEY HOW THEY VIEW THE
COMMITTEE AMENDS BUT OUR SAID
DID THEY WENT A LONG WAYS TO
FURTHER REFINING AND ADDRESS
THEIR CONCERNS WERE THEY EVER.
IF THEY'LL BE ENTIRE WE NOT I
DON'T KNOW I CAN EXPECT BUT
THAT WOULD. I THINK YOU ARE
HUNDRED AND I WOULD APPRECIATE
IF WERE SOME FOR COME. ON THAT
I DON'T WANT THE AND UNINTENDED
ONCE TO BE TO SOME OF THE
FACILITY IN BILLS. I AND MY SEC
QUESTION IS HOW IS THIS COVERT
RELATED- SCIENCE HAS INDICATED
THAT COLD IT WAS TRANSMITTED BY
HUMANS TO. ANIMALS AT I SEE THE
COURT IN BETWEEN THE COVERT
RELATED WE WERE UNDER A LOT OF
PRESSURE RIGHT NOW TO. TO LOOK
AT CODE RELATED- BILLS DON'T
SEE THE CORRELATION TO. FURTHER
ELABORATE ON. OF COURSE AND I
WOULD HAVE DONE THAT AT THE TOP
I APPRECIATE. THE FACT THAT
WE'VE TAKEN THIS MUCH TIME OUT
OF YOUR DAY IN AND IN A TOTAL
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS. IS
ALREADY AN INDULGENT REQUIRES
AN EXPLANATION I APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING THAT UP AND I AGREE WE
SHOULD BE- HI SCRUTINIZED FOR
EVERY SINGLE BILL WE PUT BEFORE
YOU AND PULL AWAY FROM- THE
REST THIS CRATE. TWO THINGS ONE
IS I THINK THE SIGN COMPLETELY
SETTLED ON THE ORIGINS OF THE
VIRUS I KNOW ABOUT THE HUMAN
THE ANIMAL TRANSMISSION I KNOW
THERE'S STILL SOME ONGOING
RESEARCH THE IN TERMS OF- HOW
LABORATORIES HAVE BEEN LOOKING
AT- THAT PAYING BILLION OR
OTHER- OTHER SORT OF SHE'S
TRANSMISSION OF THESE KIND OF
NOVEL OF I REPEAT THE NOVEL
INFLUENZA VIRUSES SO. I DON'T
THINK IT'S- ANYTHING IT GENERAL
AS WE SEE THROUGH. AB INFLUENZA
A NUMBER OF THESE MAJOR PUBLIC
HEALTH DO NOT A TRANSMISSION IS
A MAJOR RISK IT'S BEEN CITED BY
WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION YOU
SEE I MEAN THIS IS NOT.
SOMETHING THAT- WE SORT OF
CRAFTED OURSELVES TO JUSTIFY-
OF A PUSH HERE ON THAT ON THAT
LIVE ANIMAL PIECE OF IT THAT
WILDLIFE IMPORTATION DO NOT A
TRADE MISSION. AS FAR AS THE
TROPHY HUNTING PIECE OF THIS
GOES IF YOU WANT TO CALL THAT
THE- IN SUMMARY THE TROPHY
HUNTING P. THIS EXTINCTION
EVENT THAT WE'RE GOING TO IS
NOT GOING TO WAIT FOR COPAYS-
WE THINK THAT YOU KNOW WE'RE
GOING TO LOSE OUR APEX SPECIES
AND- MATT. THEM COLLAPSE IN
PARALLEL TO THIS KOBE CRISIS SO
I DON'T THINK THAT IN ANY WAY
IMPEDE OUR ABILITY TO FIGHT THE
PANDEMIC AND IN FACT YOU KNOW.
WE'VE GOT TO BE ABLE TO FIGHT
YOU BATTLES OF THE SAME TIME
AND THE SAME IS TRUE FOR. NO NO.
OUR TOOLS AND SAY WE'VE GOT A
BECAUSE ON MAGIC EVENT I THINK
WE'VE GOT AT LEAST PUT THEM
BUILDING PLACE GET IT
ENFORCEMENT ARCHITECTURE UP AND
KEEP MOVING SO THAT'S MY
ARGUMENT I APPRECIATE THE
YOU'VE GOT A LOT ELSE GOING ON
SO AM I APOLOGIZE FOR. TODAY TO
PASS ISSUE FOR ME. THANK YOU. I
HAVE A COUPLE MORE QUESTIONS
ACTUALLY. SOLD SOLD TO YOUR
POINT ABOUT- THE TRANSMISSION
WERE HAVING A VERY DIFFICULT
TIME TRACING PEOPLE. WHO HAVE
BEEN INFECTED WITH COAL BID AND
HOW ARE YOU PROPOSING TO TRACE
ANY DOES YOUR OWN VIRUS. I FROM
ANIMAL TO ANIMAL I UNDERSTAND
THE OVERALL GOAL HOWEVER WE
DIDN'T FINDING COALBED- WHEN WE
WERE YOU KNOW WHEN IT OF
ORIGINATED SO HOW ARE WE
PROPOSING THAT. THESE ANIMALS
ARE GOING TO BE. I DO YOU'RE
GONNA FIND IS DISEASES ON
ANIMAL THAN SOME OF THE- HEAD
OF IT BEFORE IT IT HURTS PEOPLE.
AND THAT SOME OF OUR EXPERTS
MAY- IT WILL HAVE SOME FURTHER
LIKE MORE DETAIL WHICH
UNIVERSITIES ARE DOING SOME OF
THE RESEARCH BUT I KNOW IT AT
LEAST. WITHIN OUR UC SYSTEM IN
SOME OF OUR MAJOR AGRICULTURAL
UNIVERSITIES AS WELL. AND
DISEASE PREVENTION AND
MITIGATION IS A- BIG ARE IN BE
EFFORT THAT ONGOING THERE'S-
BACK LABORATORY THERE ARE
VARIOUS PASSED LABORATORIES-
THERE'S ALL KINDS. OF ONGOING
RESEARCH WE'RE DOING THE STATE
TO TRY TO GET AHEAD OF WHAT
MIGHT BE A NEW FIRE I KNOW IT
THE AVIAN INFLUENZA DIFFERENCES
WERE STUDY WITH THE UC SYSTEM
IN THE SEA IS USED. SO IN
THEORY WE'D WE'D BE ABLE TO
SPOT PLEASE REGISTER EARLY AND
DO A LOT BETTER JOB OF.
MITIGATING OF ALL OUT. I WE
SHARE THE GOAL WITH OUR
PARTNERS IN THE AG. COMMUNITY
TO SLICE DOCTOR AT RISK FROM
THESE KIND OUTBREAKS AS WELL SO
I THINK THERE'S A PRETTY BIG
ARCHITECTURE IN THE STATE BUT-
CAN I PROMISE YOU IT'LL BE.
PERFECT IN WILL BE ABLE TO
BLOCK EVERYTHING NO NO I
WOULDN'T SAY THAT I THINK JUST
TRYING TO PUT MORE TOOLS AND
TOOL KIT. THANK YOU BYE YOU
JUST BROUGHT UP ANOTHER CONCERN
I READ THROUGH THE BILL AND
PART OF THE LANGUAGE. ABOUT OUR
UNIVERSITIES HAVING TO APPLY
FOR PERMITS- IN ORDER TO DO WE-
SOLD. FAYE I AREA KAPALI POMONA
DOES NOT I HAVE THEM IN. TWO
TWO APPLY SO THEN THE RESEARCH
IS NOT GOING TO BE THEM. TO THE
THEY HAVE APPLIED PAY FOR THE-
IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO DO THIS
RESEARCH SERVICE REQUEST
RESEARCHER TALKING ABOUT IS
GOING TO BE LIMITED. TO THOSE
BOB ACTUALLY APPLYING FOR IT
AND IF. YOU BEING A IF I HAVE
OTHER. MORE IMPORTANT THINGS TO
DO RESEARCH BY MIGHT NOT BE ON
THE TOP OF THE LIST SPECIAL YOU
ARE LOOKING ME THROUGH HER BOTH
TO ME. CAN MEET. FOUND ON. SHE.
IF THE VERY STRONG. AND I WOULD
SAY LET'S LET'S TRY TO FIGURE
OUT A WAY THAT WE DON'T- BIAS
OR HAVE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
FOR THESE CRITICAL RESEARCH
OPERATIONS I'M I'M OPEN TO
LOOKING AT. YOU KNOW FINANCIAL
CAPACITY I'M I'M NOT I'M JUST
TRYING TO THINK OF MY TOES HERE
A LITTLE BIT BUT SOME WAY TO
MAKE SURE THAT THERE WASN'T A
DISCRIMINATORY EFFECT. ON ANY
UNIVERSITY THAT COULDN'T FOR
SOME REASON DEAL WITH THE-
PERMITTING COST I DON'T KNOW.
THE DEPARTMENT ON THE LINE-
PRESIDENT BUT IT'S SOMETHING WE
CAN LOOK INTO I TERMS THE CALL
COSTS ISSUE. I THINK IT'S A
VERY FAIR POINT FAMILY MEMBER.
THANK YOU THAT THE HAS BEEN
INCOMING PHONE UP THAT YOU'RE
WITNESSES IF I'M I BELIEVE I'M
ON ME THAT I CAN ANSWER THAT
QUESTION. UNDER EXISTING LAW-
UNIVERSITIES AND OTHER RESEARCH
INSTITUTIONS. AS A WHOLE ARE
EXEMPTED FROM MOST PERMITTING
REQUIREMENTS. UNDER THIS BILL.
THE ONLY CHANGE TO THAT WOULD
BE ONE PROVISION REQUIRES A
LEFT A VERY VERY SMALL LIST OF
THE MOST DANGEROUS. THE ONES
THAT ARE THOUGHT TO BE THE
MOST- LIKELY TO BE OF CONCERN
THOSE DON'T GET ADDED TO THE
LEFT. AND THERE IT'S BEEN AN
EXEMPTION. TO ALLOW PERMITS.
FOR CERTAIN RESEARCH
INSTITUTIONS THAT CAN MEET THE
STANDARDS TO HANDLE THE VERY
VERY DANGEROUS ANIMALS BUT THE
VAST MAJORITY OF ANIMALS THAT
COME INTO THE CALIFORNIA FOR
RESEARCH CARPETS ARE NOT
OTHERWISE TOUCHED. BY BY THIS
STATUTE BECAUSE THERE'S A BUILT
AN EXEMPTION FOR BOTH RESEARCH
AND WELLAS INITIAL QUESTION
ACCREDITED DO A LOGICAL
ORGANIZATIONS ARE ALSO. LARGELY
EXEMPTED FROM THIS PROVISION-
AND ONE OTHER THING I CAN ADD
TO THE- ON THE QUESTION ABOUT
THE BILL WAS AMENDED- I
COMMITTEE ORIGINALLY IS WRITTEN
IT WOULD PROHIBIT IMPORT UNLESS
THAT ANIMAL COULD BE TESTED TO
ENSURE THEY WERE NOT QUITE.
CARRIERS THAT WAS THE ISSUE OF
CONCERN THAT WAS AMENDED TO.
ALLOW FOR QUARANTINE FACILITIES
AND OTHER REASONABLE MEASURES
TO ENSURE THAT ANY ANIMALS THAT
ARE BROUGHT IN THAT ARE TESTED
TO HAVE CONCERNS CAN BE SAFELY
TREATED THAT WOULD NOT ACT AS A
BAN. ON THE IMPORTATION OF
ANIMALS TO THE SMALLER ZOOS IT
WOULD JUST ENSURE THAT THEY'RE
NOT BRINGING IN ANIMALS WITHOUT
SOME LEVEL OF ABILITY TO TREAT
THEM. AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY OTHER. THE BILL. IN MY
CONCERN IS THAT THE UNIVERSITY
ARE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO JUMP
THROUGH HOOPS IN ORDER TO DO
THIS RESEARCH AT THE NOW-
THAT'S THE ONLY WAY WE'RE GOING
TO- YOU KNOW A GOOD PASS SOME
OF THESE- VIRUSES AND DISEASES
SO I'D BE HAPPY TO TALK TO YOU
BUT BY THE TIME OF THEM BE WERE.
ON AUGUST. THIRD AND THIS IS ON
THE FAST TRACK TO THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR SO. WHEN DO YOU PROPOSE
THAT SOME OF THESE ISSUES CAN
B. RESOLVED OR AT LEASTTHE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE- THE-
INTERESTED. ARE THE AFFECTED
PARTIES CAN HAPPEN. I'M READY
TO DO THAT TOMORROW WITH YOU
HOWEVER YOU'D LIKE I I'M I'M
READY TO. RECONVENE WHAT WHEN
AND THEY CAN BE WHATEVER CROSS
SECTION OF THESE GROUPS AND SEE
IF WE CAN. AFTER EVERYONE
DIGESTED WHAT'S IN THE AMENDED
SOME OF ITSEXISTING LAW THAT
RENDON BROUGHT UP. ALL THAT ON
THE TABLE TALK IT THROUGH AND-
LOOK IF YOU CAN'T REACH A
RESOLUTION I TOTALLY RESPECT
THAT SOME PEOPLE WON'T SUPPORT
THE BILL IN THE END BUT I
REALLY. I THINK WE'RE I THINK
WE'RE DARN CLOSE- I THINK THE
COMMITTEE AMENDS LIKE YEAH I'VE
GOT A SPARE BUT BUT YOU HAVE
APPROACH- I'M SURE THERE WILL
BE SOME COST SO I WOULD IMAGINE
YOU'LL HAVE A MOMENT. AGO YOU
KNOW WE GET WE GET ONE BITE AT
THE APPLE THERE SO I DON'T.
THIS YOU AND TRY TO FAST TRACK
WITHOUT. ONE MORE BITE AT THE
APPLE SO I WILL SIT DOWN AS
SOON AS- YEAH SENATORS CAN
CONVENIENT FEASIBLE THANK YOU-
I LITERALLY TO THE ALREADY I
MET THE TO THEM VIRTUALLY I
APOLOGIZE FOR THAT. CAN BE IN
DOUBT BUT FROM WAY WAY FOR YOU
NO WORRIES NO WORRIES. YOU KNOW
I LOOK FOR TO THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AND I WOULD
APPRECIATE IF YOU CAN KEEP ME
AND HOPEFULLY THE REST OF THE
COMMITTEE- A PRIZE AS TO WHAT'S
HAPPENING. I AND THEN- THE BILL
ALSO TALK ABOUT PROHIBITING
POSSESSION OF TROPHY ANIMALS
HOW IS THIS DOUBLE. I WOULD THE
POSSESSION THAT COMPONENT
FORCED THE IT WOULD. MEAN YOU
HAVE TO HAS A PRETTY WELL. AND
FOR ARCHITECTURE- WHERE THEY
TRACK WITH THE THEY SHOULD BE
TRACKING BLACK MARKETS IN OTHER
BANNED ITEMS SO LIKE THINK OF
OUR IVORY BAN OR- SOME OF OUR
OTHER BAND ON ANIMAL PARTS.
THOSE WE HAD TO GO BEYOND THAT
HERE BECAUSE WE THINK IT'S NOT
JUST YOU KNOW AN IVORY ISSUE
BUT THEY ALREADY HAVE AN
ARCHITECTURETHAT TRACKS A LOT
OF THE BLACK MARKET ACTIVITY
BUT TO ACTUALLY HAVE IT NOW.
JUST TRACK COMMERCE SO THEY-
THROUGH THE PERMITTING PROCESS
WHERE COME IN WITH A NEW
COMPANY. REGULATIONS THEY CAN
COME UNDER THE NEW TRUMP
VERSION OF THE AT THAT IN IN
THEIR THEIR THE TRUTH. THIS
WILL BE TRACKING AT THAT POINT
MEAN THE ABOVE BOARD PART OF
THE OF THE INDUSTRY IS PRETTY
PRETTY WELL REGULAR. WE THINK
SHOULD SHOULD WORK. IN OTHER
EIGHT. I MEAN IT IT'S NOT LIKE
THEY'RE YOU KNOW BAD PDF THAT
HE'S GONNA COME NOT ON THE TO
ANY WHO'S GOT A RELIC INTO IN
THEIR INJURED CHECK IN HOUSE BY
HOUSE HERE THAT NOT THE BILL
THE BILL IS SET UP IT KICKS IN
IN THE APPOINTED ACTIVISTS ON
TWENTY TWENTY ONE SO WITH THAT
BUT IF YOU HAVE SAY. ANYWAY I
DON'T NEED TO GO. THAT SO
WHATEVER YOU LIKE. COM THE
PERFECT SAID BECAUSE THERE'S A
WERE I AM THE BILL THERE'S A
REWARD FOR SOMEONE- TURNING IN
AN INDIVIDUAL THAT BELIEVE HAVE
A TROPHY ANIMAL. SOUL SOUL
YOU'RE SAYING THAT WE HAVE A BY
SYSTEM OF TRACING THROUGH THE-
THE BOTH THE STATE DEPARTMENT
OR THE FEDERAL DEPARTMENT
HOWEVER THERE IS A PROVISION OF
A- REWARDING SOMEONE FOR
TURNING AN INDIVIDUAL THAT FACT
HAVE THE TROPHY ANIMAL- HOW IS
THIS GOING TO WORK OUT ARE WE
LOOKING AT YOU KNOW. ACCORDING
A LOT RIGHT TO WEAR SOMEBODY
LOOKING FOR THE OF THESE AND TO
TURN IN BECAUSE OF THE REWARD
IF HE ACTS SUCH A ROBOT THE
ROBOT SYSTEM THEN WHAT IS THE
NEED FOR WORDS SYSTEM- FOR
TURNING INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
THESE. IT AWARD WE THINK IS
IMPORTANT PEOPLE WANT TO GO TO
THE BLACK MARKET AND NIGHT-
ABIDE BY ALL THE PERMITS IN
REGULATION HERE AND SO. YOU
KNOW THIS IS A- MULTI MILLION
DOLLAR INDUSTRY MEAN. THE BLACK
MARKET IN WILDLIFE TRAFFICKING
AND- TROPHIES IN PART. GLOBALLY
IS ONLY BEHIND THE DRUG TRADE
IN HUMAN TRAFFICKING SO THIS IS
NOT LIKE SOME. JEFF IT'S NOT
JUST MOM AND POPS OUT THERE ARE
PEOPLE WHO ARE. YOU KNOW- DOING
THINGS ON IT INDIVIDUAL
HOBBYIST BASIS THIS IS THERE IS
A BIG. MARKET THAT DOESN'T WANT
TO BE. I NOT NOT. MMAFIGHTING
ANY THE FOLKS WHO WERE BEEN IN
TRY TO DO THINGS ACCORDING TO
LAW SO THAT PIECE OF IT THOSE
WHO DOES WANT TO PLAY BY THE
RULES WE HOPE THAT THAT THAT
ARCHITECTURE HELPS GIVE SOME
ADDITIONAL ENFORCEMENT POWER.
THANK YOU SENATOR STERN BUT-
YOU KNOW JUST AGAIN ONE LAST
COMMENT ABOUT THAT THE ILLICIT
ARE BLACK MARKET WORD
STRUGGLING WITHOUT WITH
CANNABIS INDUSTRY AND THERE IS
NO NO- RESOLUTION AND FIGHTS I
HOPE THAT THIS DOESN'T- TURN
INTO SOMETHING LIKE THAT WHERE
THE UNDERGROUND MARKET DRIVING
BECAUSE NOW WE'RE BANNING ALL
OF THESE- YOU KNOW THE
IMPORTATION. AND AGAIN BOARD
YOU ARE COLOR BUT HAVING SINCE
WITH HOW WE CAN MAKE BETTER.
BECAUSE I'M- I'M- AS I. HOPE
YOU CAN ADDRESS SOME OF THE
CONCERNS BEFORE IT GETS TO BE A
PART. THANK YOU THANK YOU BYE
THE RUBIO I DON'T IF MY COULD
GET WE A WE HAVE A- SKEWS ME.
UP WE HAVE UNDER SOME MEMBER
WHOSE. BEEN WAITING TO A
QUESTION IN WILL WILL GO HEAD
THERE ARE. AT SOME MEMBER DE
THE MATH. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR QUESTION FOR- THE AUTHOR-
SENATOR ON PAGE TWELVE OF YOUR
BILL YOU GET INTO THE
DISCUSSION OF. FOOD MARKETS
WHAT MARKET SIX CETERA AND
BASED UPON THE LANGUAGE WITH IN
YOUR BILL- THIS MIGHT ACTUALLY
HAVE AN ADVERSE AFFECT ON SOME
OF OUR SEAFOOD MARKETS AND EVEN
SOME OF THE AND LAND- IN CASES
LIKE RED LOBSTER WHERE YOU CAN
GO IN AND PICK THE LOBSTER THAT
YOU WANT TO EAT- CAN YOU EXPAND
UPON THIS TO ENSURE THAT OUR
RETAIL RESTAURANTS THAT GO.
THROUGH ST. THE HELP AND IF THE-
GONNA HAVE ADVERSE OF TO THEM.
SHORT THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION ASSEMBLY MEMBER VISIT.
ONLY OF THOSE MOBSTERS HAVE A
RISK OF MASSIVE VIRAL INFECTION
FOR DO NOT AGREE IN THEIR PUT
BY THE DEPARTMENT AFTER
RIGOROUS STUDY THE WATCHLIST
FED BDO BDO ONLY INTERVENTION
POINT TO ANY KIND OF MARKET.
BILL THAT ARENA RIGHT SO IT'S
NOT DESIGNED A YEAH PRESIDENT
REGULATED THE RESTAURANT LEVEL
IT'S NOT DESIGNED TO GO AFTER-
RESTAURANTS BUT BUT- LOOK I
MEAN IF THERE WAS A HUGE GLOBAL
VIRUS RELATED TO HOW LACKEY A-
AND WE'RE IMPORTING TAPIA FROM
CHINA. DARN RIGHT WE BETTER YOU
KNOW TAKE IT LIKE BY STOP SELL
THAT STUFF LIVE HERE RIGHT SO I
MEAN IT'S- WE DIDN'T WANT TO.
HAVE TRY TO PUT LEUPOLD IN THAT
DO NOT A RISK SECTION SO THAT
YOU KNOW ONE COULD SLIP THROUGH
ANOTHER COULDN'T BUT THIS ISN'T
REALLY. IT'S NOT SUPPOSED TO GO
AFTER A RED LOBSTER OR MY LOCAL
SEAFOOD PLACE- AND LIKEWISE
FOR- FOR POULTRY MARKETS- FOR
YOU KNOW ANY ANY KIND OF-
BUTCHER SHOPS ANY OF THAT THIS
IS NOT. SUPPOSED TO GO AFTER
THAT KIND OF COMMERCE REALLY
JUST THE COMMERCE THAT HAS.
RISK OF. IT'S GOOD FOR IN.
THANK YOU YOU HAVE ANOTHER
QUESTION CELEBRITY. FOLLOWED BY
A DOCTOR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU SENATOR
STERN FOR BRINGING THIS BACK
LOADED FOR- A SIMILAR BILL A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO AND- IT AND
I FIND A TROPHY HUNTING TO BE
MORALLY REPUGNANT- AND OF
SOMETHING THAT MAKES NO SENSE
TO ME I DID FIND THE B. ARTICLE
THIS WEEK TO BE YOU INTERESTING.
AND CHALLENGING FOR. IS THAT
POINT AND SERVE THE POPULATIONS
OF ANIMALS- ACROSS THE WORLD-
AND PROTECT OUR ECOSYSTEM WHERE
THEY RAISE THE FACT THAT BY
BANNING TROPHY HUNTING WE MAY
IN FACT BE CURTAILING EFFORTS
TO PROTECT SPECIES BECAUSE OF
THE FUNDS THAT DOCOME IN TWO
COUNTRIES THAT ARE DOING WELL
MANAGE CONSERVATION PROGRAM
WITH THAT MONEY AND- AND IT IT
IS SO COUNTERINTUITIVE IN VERY
CHALLENGING FOR ME AND THE
WORLD VIEW. THAT DO YOU BELIEVE
IT MAKES SENSE TO TAKE SOME
TIME TO FIGURE OUT. IF WE CAN
DETERMINE WELL MANAGED PROGRAMS
THAT WE LOOK AT COUNTRY
SPECIFIC FILTERS BY WHICH WE
RECOGNIZE WHICH COUNTRIES IN
THE WORLD ARE NOT CONSERVING
ANIMAL POPULATIONS PROPERLY
THAT ARE NOT USING THE FUNDS
COLLECTED TO DO IT PROPERLY AND
AGAIN I BELIEVE IT'S MORALLY
REPUGNANT IT IS IMMORAL. TO DO
I TO DO TROPHY HUNTING IT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT I UNDERSTAND BUT
WE HAVE WE'RE WE'RE WORKING ON
THE VERY SAME GOAL TO ONE LIMIT
HARM TO ANIMALS AND ALSO WELL
THE TWO GOALS LIMIT HARM TO
ANIMALS THE PAIN AND SUFFERING
THAT THEY UNDERGO. AND ALL. TO
BACK THE POPULATION. ONE
AMAZING SPEED OF WHY THAT
SHOULD BE HERE FOREVER- THAT
HUMAN ACTION IS ACTIVELY- HURT
YOU KNOW ENDING THE SPECIES
TIME ON THIS PLANET AND- AND SO
AGAIN VERY COUNTER INTUITIVE
FOR ME TO READ A HOW BY US IN
THE WAY THAT WE VIEW THE WORLD.
AT THE WAY TO SET POLICY COULD
END UP ACTUALLY HARMING SOME OF
OUR GOALS AND SO I IN. TO FOR
THIS TODAY BUT SENATORS I WOULD
REALLY LIKE YOU TO WITH I YOUR
TEAM TO DETERMINE IF THERE'S A
WAY TO EFFECTIVELY PROTECTS BE
USED AT THE FACT IN GROSS
SPECIES AND IN A WAY TO DO THIS
IN A WAY A IN AN S. A POLICY
SETTING. I KNOW FOR THE THOSE
THAT ARE LIKE ME. THAT HAVE
EXTRAORDINARILY- EXTRAORDINARY
STRONG MORAL CONCERNS ABOUT IT
IT IS ANATHEMA TO WAY THAT WE
FEEL IN THE WAY THAT WE SEE
THIS ISSUE- AND SO THIS PART.
BOB IS THE NOMINATION CHALLENGE
OUR WRLD VIEWS. BUT I IT WOULD
BE GOOD TO SEE WHAT THE
OUTCOMES. OF LAWS LIKE THIS
WOULD BE RATHER THAN THE STATED
GOALS- NOT MEETING. THE
OUTCOMES WERE LOOKING FOR. I
ALSOWANT TO TAKE NOTE THAT
WE'RE DOING THE WORK OF THE
LEGISLATURE TODAY. WE'RE
LOOKING AT A POLICY ISSUE ONE
THAT WE'VE WRESTLED WITH FOR
YEARS. WE ARE ALSO DOING THIS
DURING THE COVE A PANDEMIC. AND
THIS IS NOT A BILL THAT I THINK
FITS UNDER- THE LANDS OF. KOBE
OR EMERGENCY SPECIFIC
LEGISLATION THAT SOME WOULD SAY
WE HAVE TO FOCUS ON SO SENATOR
STERN. WE'RE WE'RE GIVING YOU A
LOT OF TIME HERE TODAY TO
WRESTLE WITH THIS IMPORTANT
POLICY ISSUE I WISH THAT YOU
WOULD TALK TO YOUR COLLEAGUES.
ABOUT DOING THE SAME. BUT MAYBE
EVEN JUST ON CO THAT ARE WILD
FIRE RELATED BILLS THAT YOUR
HOUSE HAS JUST FAILED US ON
THANK YOU. THANK YOU DOT. THANK
YOU CHAIR ARE. AND THE SENATOR
STERN. YOU'D LIKE TO RESPOND I
WOULD LIKE HIM TO HEAR TO
RESPOND ABOUT THE WAY THAT IT'S
YOUR TURN TIMES. LET'S NOT
LET'S YOU'LL THE TIME TO THE
AUTHOR YEAH THANK YOU. YOU AN
APOLOGY DOCTOR CHOI WILL BE
WITH YOU SHORTLY THANK YOU SO
MEMBER FOR YOUR YOUR COMMENTS-
AND FOR YOUR PASSED IN. SOUNDS
LIKE CURRENT SUPPORT- I DO I DO
THINK THE MASS EXTINCTION EVENT
IS AN EMERGENCY WORTHY OF
IMMEDIATE ACTION I THINK THE
CLIMATE CRISIS WRIT LARGE CAN'T
WAIT. A COUPLE THAT I THINK WE
GOT TO DO BOTH AT THE SAME TIME
SO THAT WOULD BE BY SEVENTY OF
ARGUMENT I APPRECIATE YOUR
YOUR- TWENTY. COMEDY AND
PROGRESS HERE AND I
WHOLEHEARTEDLY AGREE WITH YOU
THERE I THINK- WILD FIRE FROM
THESE OTHER VERY URGENT ISSUES
ALSO SHOULD BE HEARD. AND I
HOPE WE CAN FIND. A WHOLE LOT
OF PROGRESS- ON A BICAMERAL
BASIS IN THE WEEK AHEAD ON A
SPECIFIC QUESTION ABOUT. THE
ECONOMIC IMPACT OF THIS
LEGISLATION AND WHETHER IT IT
SORT OF YEAH UNINTENTIONALLY
MIGHT- DO DO SOME HARM TO
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST
POPULATIONS THAT DEPEND ON. THE
HUNTING AND THREE I WOULD SAY
TWO THINGS ONE IS. THE BILL
ACTUALLY BUT THEN. BEGAN TO BE
HUNTING. YOU CAN STILL GO TO
ZIMBABWE AND PAY FORTY THOUSAND
OUT. IN ORDER TO OPEN IN A- TEN
TIMES YOU WANT A FIVE MINUTE
PERIOD HOWEVER THE HUNT GOES AS
WE'VE SEEN IN STARK RELIEF BUT
IF THAT IS YOU TO. ANY ON YOU
CAN GO AND YOUR MONEY ON THAT-
AND YOU GET. HAD ALL AND PUT IT
ON YOUR WAY THE STATE. WHEN I
CAN BE PART OF COMMERCE THIS
BILL. BUT WE ALL. THEY'RE ALL
OVER IS A MY MORE POTENT TWAY.
T. IF YOU WANT TO USE THAT
ELEPHANT SAY AS COMMERCE. THAT
ELEPHANT OVER A LIFETIME THE
STATE ALIVE IS GOING TO
GENERATE OVER A MILLION DOLLARS
IN ECO TOURISM ACCORDING TO NOW
YOU SEE. EDDIE OVER MILLION.
YOU GET A FORTY THOUSAND DOLLAR
TO PERMIT ONE GUY ONE. WITH
WHATEVER THAT HUNTING PARTY IS
AND THAT'S IT SO THAT'S WHY
STEP A NUMBER OF STUDIES HAVE
SHOWN MUCH MORE JOB IN A LOCAL.
THE BILL BENEFIT FROM CONSERVE.
THEN HUNTER. I WOULD LOVE HEAR
FROM THE TESTING THE LEAD TO
MONEY OWN IT. WOULD LOVE TO
KNOW. ALL THE DOT FLOW IS. TING
AN AFRICAN MAYES RIGHT THE THAT
IS BEEN HARD COME BY OF WHEN
THE MONEY. TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. AND THEN HOW MUCH
OF IT ACTUALLY DOES FLOW BACK
TO THAT LOCAL COMMUNITY- IT'S
BEEN TRICKY TO GET THAT DATA
BUT IT APPEARS TO BE A LOT.
STOPS ALONG THE WAY- BEYOND
NOTION THAT SOMEHOW THIS IS
GOING TO. BE AN IMPEDIMENT IF
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION HADN'T
DID VOMIT DELAYS. BUT BECAUSE
THEY WANT TO. COME BACK WE
THEIR OWN EL TAILED OTHER SURE
TO FOR OUR HERE AND I THINK
THIS IS A REASONABLE RESPONSE
I'D LOVE TO BE ABLE TO VISIT. A
SORT OF GLOBAL CONSERVATION
POLICY. IN A IN A MORE KIND OF
RATIONAL. BUT RIGHT NOW I THINK
WE GOT A GUEST. ACT ON AN
EMERGENCY BASIS AND DO WHAT WE
CAN TO PREVENT THIS EXTINCTION
OF AT. THE SOME OF AS A FOLLOW
UP. YEAH I JUST WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
SENATOR FOR- FOR HIS ANSWERS
THAT QUESTION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU DOCTOR TRUCK. OKAY SENATORS
STERN- YOU. CAN UNDERSTAND ARE
YOUR. INTENT OF THIS BILL. AND
THEN I HAVE A TO AREAS OF ALL
COURT PROCESS AND- I IN YOUR
BILL TAXED ORDER PART. YOU ARE
SAYING THAT SO ALMOST A SIXTY
PERCENT OF ROMA- SO NOT A-
DISEASES AND OVER 70% OF THIS
ALL ASSUMES IS OUR OFFER ALMA
Y. LARGE. ART IS- YOU WERE
GUESTS ALL WAR IS A SCIENTIFIC
DATA THAT YOU HAVE BASED.
BECAUSE MY- FIRST QUESTION.
SECOND QUESTION IS THAT THE
LINE ELEVEN- ARE YOU ARE SAYING
THAT. FIRST AND THE POOR WITH
NINETEEN WERE LIKELY COST BY A
TRANSMISSION BETWEEN POOR
ANYMORE SPACES FOLLOW THE BY
OUR TRANSMISSION TO HUMANS WITH
THE CASES THAT INITIAL A
SPREADING TOTAL MUST FOR SPACES.
I WONDER WHETHER THIS IS SAW
THE WORD LIKELY COSTS. BY YA
ANYMORE TO SHOW MY- I DON'T
KNOW EXACTLY BUT I KNOW THAT
THE ONE PROFESSOR FROM. HONG
KONG WHO DEFECTED TOOK TO RAW
THE UNITED STATES STATED THAT
THE COFFEE NINETEEN VIRUS
AWHILE ALL. MANUFACTURED IN A
LABORATORY. DOES A ONE ONE
FEWER UNIT IN THE SHE CLAIMS.
AND I KNOW YOU ARE CLAIMING
THIS IS UNLIKELY COSTA BY
ANYONE ELSE. CAN YOU CLARIFY
WHETHER THIS IS SO BASED ON
FORM UPON OUR ANY SCIENTIFIC
DATA OR IS A LIKELY COSTA WAS
FOR YOUR OPINION. VERY GOOD- I
LET ME IF YOU DON'T MINDACTED
CHOI I'LL DO A HIGH LEVEL
ANSWER AND THEN I'M GOING TO
SEND IT TO- IF I DON'T HAVE THE
EXACT RIGHT CITATIONS FOR YOU
I'M GOING TO. GIVE MY EXPERT
THE CHANCE TO GIVE ME HELP ME
WITH THE FOOTNOTES HERE. YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE FINDINGS. HI
I AM I RIGHT YOU WERE IN
SECTION ONE OF THE BILL. SORRY
HE BILL HAD GONE IN ANOTHER
QUESTION AGAIN MISTER THIS THIS
IS SAID AND DONE THE FINDING
SECTION DR YEAH THIS IS A FROM
THE EARLY PART OF YOUR SECTION
YOUR EXACT. ONE OF FIRST PAN
OKAY UNDERSTANDING EVEN MONEY
NOT GOT IT. YES SO WHAT THERE
ARE A FEW CITED JOURNALS AND
ALL THAT- DVD OR SKILL FILL IN
THE SIXTY AND SEVENTY PERCENT-
NUMBERS BUT- YOU KNOW WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION IS
CERTAINLY ONE OF THE CORE
INSTITUTIONS WE'VE BEEN RELYING
ON FOR A LOT OF THIS
TRANSMISSION DATA- AND IN TERMS
OF THE- THE LIKELY CAUSE-
LANGUAGE. THAT THAT DIDN'T
REFER SPECIFICALLY TO THE
ORIGINS OF COAL BID- I THINK
THE WAY WE WHAT WE WROTE IT WAS
SORT OF MORE BROADLY AROUND-
THE LIKELY DISEASES AS OPPOSED
TO LIKELY CAUSES SO THAT- THIS
IS OFTEN. NOT POSSIBLE TO
DETERMINE EXACTLY WHAT IF IT IS
NOT A DISEASE BUT BUT MANY OF
THE- FINDING AS A VETERINARY
PUBLIC HEALTH SECTION AT THE
STATE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH IS FOUND THAT- DEAD BUT
IT THOSE THAT THEY ARE LIKELY
DISEASES THAT HAVE. IMPACTED
CALIFORNIA NOT JUST PEOPLE BUT
ALSO WILDLIFE. I PRINTED I
WOULD. IF IT YEAH MADE ME HATE
MAKE ME SOUND A LITTLE MORE-
WELL CITED HERE IN MY SEARCH IT
OKAY YEAH HAPPY TO ANSWER THOSE
QUESTIONS. SO THAT THE
STATEMENT THAT AT 60% OF
INFECTIOUS DISEASE. I DO NOT
ACT AND 70% OF THE DOCTOR THE
THAT COME FROM WILDLIFE- THOSE
NUMBERS ARE DIRECTLY FROM THE
CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL- WE
CAN SEND YOU A LINK TO THEIR
WEBSITE THAT HAS THEIR- THEIR
FACT IN BACKGROUND. HAS NOT
ACTED THE THAT. WILL THEN FELT
HAVE MULTIPLE OTHER SITES- AND
SIMILAR NUMBERS ARE USED BY
THE- WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION
FOR THAT THOSE NUMBERS ARE I
WOULD SAY PRETTY MUCH
INDISPUTABLE. AS TO THE
LIKELIHOOD OF A CO. THEY THAT
ALSO- PRETTY MUCH AND IT'S
BEAUTIFUL SORRY WE KNOW CAME
FROM- AT THAT. JUMPED TO
OBSERVE IT AND THEN TO PEOPLE
FOR COLD AND IT'S ABOUT 99%
CERTAIN THAT IT ORIGINATED IN A
HORSESHOE BAT- WHICH IS A TYPE
OF THAT IS MANY VARIETIES THERE
IS NUMEROUS. STARTS RELATIVE
VIRUSES THAT HAVE BEEN FOUND IN
THE FAMILY BACK. THE ONLY
SCIENTIFIC UNCERTAINTY IS
WHETHER IT WENT BROWN OF COURSE
YOU BACK. DIRECTLY TO PEOPLE OR
WENT TO ANOTHER ANIMA FIRST.
LIKELY A PANGOLIN AND THEN TO
PEOPLE- THAT'S STILL BEING CUTE
DOUBT BUT IT'S UNDISPUTED THAT-
THE VIRUS ORIGINATED IN THE
BACK- SO WHERE FULLY
COMFORTABLE OUT WITH A
STATEMENT IN THE LEGISLATIVE
FINDINGS. THANK YOU YOU HAVE A
ANOTHER QUESTION FROM A SO
MEMBER OFF OF CARL. WILL BE THE
THANK YOU CHAIR- JUST WANT TO
MAKE A COUPLE COMMENTS ON ON
THE OFFICIAL LIKE TO MOVE THE
BILL. I DON'T KNOW THERE'S BEEN
A MOTION FOR THE MOTION FOR.
THANK YOU I'M AND A COUPLE
THINGS FIRST OF ALL AS TO
HEARING THE HEARING OF THIS
BILL. NOW SETTING ASIDE ANY
INTER HOUSE FRUSTRATIONS THE
REALITY IS THAT OUR SPEAKERS
GIVEN US THE DISCRETION. TO
HEAR BILLS EVEN IF THEY'RE NOT
COVER RELATED IF UNDER
DISCUSSION OF THE CHAIR- I
HEARD NINE BILLS AS LABOR CHAIR
NOT ALL RECALLS RELATED AND I
HAD THE RIGHT AND ABILITY TO DO
THAT AS CHAIR AND I FULLY
SUPPORT. OUR CHAIRS DECISION
FOR HAVING THIS BILL HEARD- AND
IT DOES FOR IT'S AN ABSOLUTELY
FALLS WITHIN THE DISCRETION
THAT OF AND GUIDANCE I SHOULD
SAY- FROM OUR SPEAKER AND
LEADERSHIP AND SO- YOU KNOW I'M
HAPPY THAT THIS BILL IS BEFORE
US TODAY. I ALSO DO BELIEVE
THAT IT IS RELEVANT- AS TO SOME
OF THE COMMENTS FROM OF EXPERT
TESTIMONY AS WELL AS SENATOR
STERN- WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THE
IMPORTATION. OF ANIMALS TALK
ABOUT MARKET. HAS SOMEHOW BEEN
RELATED- WITH- THE
INTERMINGLING OF HUMANS AND
WILDLIFE FOR ANIMALS OF SOME
SORT- AND AS WAS JUST INDICATED
THAT'S LIKELY THE CASE HERE SO.
REGARDLESS WHETHER IS DIRECTLY
RELATED TO THE TRANSMISSION OF
COVERT SPECIFICALLY THE REALITY
IS THAT WE DO NOW- THAT THERE
IS ALWAYS A RISK- WILL WIN AS
PER PARTICULARLY WHEN YOU HAVE-
ANIMALS SO THAT ARE NOT WITHIN
THE MAINSTREAM. OF IMPORTATION
FOR SOME RAP UP THE TROPHY
ANIMALS OR IN SOME CASES SOME
OF THESE- ANIMAL IMPORTATION
THAT IS MORE UNIQUE- CERTAINLY.
UP AND TO THE ISSUE AT HAND-
PARTICULARLY SINCE WE HEARD.
MOSTLY OF A GARDEN THAT THE
CHAU. ANIMAL ASPECT OF IT HOW
DOES A COUPLE THINGS ONE IS-
LOOK AT BOTH OF THE SCIENCE-
AND THE DATA AND I THINK YOU
LOOK THE SCIENCE THE DATA ON
THE ACTUAL REPORTS. AN
INTERNATIONAL POURS SHOW THEY
WILL SHOW THAT THE IMPACT OF
ECO TOUR TOURISM ECONOMICALLY-
IS FAR OUTPACING OF THAT ACT
I'M A CAPTIVITY. UP FROM FEE
HUNTING. AND SO. THE REALITY IS
THAT ALWAYS GOING TO BE SOME
INTERESTS THAT ARE GOING TO
WANT TO MAINTAIN- SOME FLOW OF
THE ECONOMY- INTO THEIR COFFERS
AND AS INDICATED BY THE AUTHOR-
THEM THE MANAGEMENT OF THOSE
RESOURCES. OF IS ALSO. A
QUESTION. HOWEVER ULTIMATELY.
THIS ISN'T. ABOUT A JUDGMENT ON
THE MORALITY OF ACTIONS. OF
OTHERS OR OF NATIONS AND
APHRODITE IT THIS HAS TO DO
WITH US- THE THIS IS A JUDGMENT
OF OUR OWN REALITY WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT THE- BUT THEY CAN
DO- WE'RE MAKING A STATEMENT ON
WHAT WE'RE WILLING. TO INDOOR.
AND SO IF WE GET IT NOT JUST
MORALLY BUT SCIENTIFICALLY AND
ECONOMICALLY- CALIFORNIA DOES
PLAY AN IMPORTANT ROLE- AND THE
REALITY IS WE WOULDN'T BE HERE.
IF THE CURRENT ADMINISTRATION
DIDN'T ROLL BACK ONCE AGAIN A
NOTHER OBAMA- ERA- REGULATION.
AND THERE HAVE BEEN DOZENS
RELATED TO THE ENVIRONMENT THIS
ADMINISTRATION IS ALL ABOUT
INCLUDING A BILL BUT I HAD. A
PASSED AND SIGNED BY SIGNED
INTO LAW THE MIGRATORY BIRD
PROTECTION ACT WHICH WAS
ACTIVATED TO AND OBAMA ERA. ARE
ACTUALLY ONE HUNDRED YEAR-
TREATY THE PUNCH WAS IN AND- A
PART OF THIS ADMINISTRATION
ROLLED BACK. IN SO. WE HAVE.
ALL OF WE DON'T WE HAVE A LOT
OF INFLUENCE. AS A STATE OF IF
WE LOOK AT WHAT WE JUST DID
RECENTLY IN LAST COUPLE YEARS.
ON BANNING THE SALE OF
COSMETICS THAT HAVE ANY ANIMAL
TESTING WE WERE TOLD. THAT IT
WAS GONNA BE TOLL THE-
DESTROYER MARKET BECAUSE
CHINA'S OFTEN ALLOW US TO
IMPORT. BECAUSE MEDICS WHAT
HAPPENED AFTER THAT. CHINA'S
HARD RELAX THOSE RULES BECAUSE
OF THE INFLUENCE OF OUR MARKET.
DOES THE INFLUENCE OF THE
DECISIONS THAT WE MAKE- IN
ENVIRONMENTAL STEWARDSHIP AND
LEADERSHIP AND ANIMAL
PROTECTION. WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO ONCE AGAIN MAKE
A CLEAR STATEMENT. AS TO WHERE
OUR VALUES ARE- TO NOT
CONTRIBUTE. TO A PRACTICE- THAT
IS FAR MORE DETRIMENTAL TO THE
ENVIRONMENT EVEN IN TERMS OF
CONSERVATION CERTAIN. THE ECO
TOURISM- BUT IN TERMS OF. IF
YOU LOOK AT WHAT THESE ANIMALS
ARE EXTINCT IS BECAUSE OF THE
PRACTICE. BUT YEAH CAN BE A
PRACTICE. IS THAT MAY BETTER
THAN WHAT IS AB THE PAST PLUS
BUT. IT DOESN'T MAKE IT MORE
VIABLE BUT- ECONOMICALLY IT
DOESN'T MAKE MORE PROTECTIVE
SCIENTIFICALLY AND IT DOESN'T
MAKE IT- MORE OF MORAL-
INAPPROPRIATE- THEN FOCUSING ON
OTHER WAYS. TO CONSERVE AND
AGAIN- JUST UNDER CERTAIN POINT
WE'RE NOT TELLING ANYONE ELSE
WHAT TO DO. WE'RE JUST MAKING-
WE'RE MAKING A GESTURE BASED
UPON OUR OWN MORALITY THAT
DISTANCE WITH- WHERE OUR NATION
WAS JUST. FOUR YEARS AGO. THANK
YOU MISTER THANK YOU FOR THIS
COMMENT YEAH I KNOW THAT YOU'LL
SEE ANY OTHER MICROPHONES UP OF
THE STRUGGLE OF. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR ON TO THE AUTHOR I
APPRECIATE YOUR- DILIGENCE IN
TRYING TO RESPOND EVERYONE'S
QUESTIONS. I JUST WANT TO COME
BACK TO- RECOGNIZING- THIS
RUBIO QUESTIONS THAT SHE HAD-
YOUR SECTION THAT YOU SPOKE
ABOUT DOESN'T SPECIFICALLY.
WHEN YOU ANSWERED HER.
MENTIONED ZOOS IT ALSO DOES NOT
MENTION SANCTUARIES. THERE ARE
A NUMBER SANCTUARY- FACILITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ONE OF THEM HAPPENS
TO BE THE LARGEST ONE IN THE
STATE AND IT'S MY DISTRICT. MY
CONCERN IS THAT THEY MIGHT BE
AFFECTED. AND I. THIS YOU
ADDRESS YOUR BILL YOU'RE GOING
AND WORKING WITH MISS RUBIO ON
ON THESE AMENDMENTS TO MAKE
SURE YOU INCLUDE THE
SANCTUARIES AND THEIR ABILITY
TO CONTINUE TO FACILITATE OUR
THEIR THEIR MISSIONS AND GOALS
TO PROTECT AND PRESERVE. SURE
YOU MIGHT. PLEASE OKAY THANK
YOU FAMILY MEMBER. I AM
COMMITTED TO REFINING FURTHER
THE BILL IF NECESSARY WITH MISS
RUBIO AND HAPPY TO INCLUDE YOU
IN THOSE CONVERSATIONS I ALSO
ACTUALLY HAVE I HAVE A SMALL
ZOO IN THE NORTH PART OF MY
DISTRICT I HAVE GIVEN SANCTUARY
IN THE SANTA CLARITA PAR THE
DISTRICT I BORDER WITH- SENATOR
WILL OKAY I HAVE A- MAJOR
WILDLIFE THANK CENTURY RIGHT
NEAR WHERE I LIVE THAT DOES A
LOT OF MARINE LIFE SO I'M I'M
REALLY INTO TO ALL THIS. TO
WHAT AT WHAT I WHEN I TALK THEM
AND WILL I THINK THE COMMITTEE
AMENDED TRIED TO DO IS SAY WE
GET TO KEEP MOVING ANIMALS IN
THE CENTURIES OR THEY CAN KEEP
COMING MALL ZOOS OR ANY OF THE
BIG THING CHAIR OF THE COMMERCE
OR NONPROFIT. BUT THAT IT IS
SEEKING. DO NOT A TRADE RISK OF
AN IN. SPECIES RIGHT OF AN OF
AN AVID OUTSIDE. THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ANIMAL- THAT. IT'S
GOT TO BE SUBJECT TO SOME KIND
OF SCRUTINY AT THE VFW- BEYOND
WHAT'S CURRENTLY BEING IMPOSED
IF WE IF WE NEED TO REFINE THAT
FURTHER I'M- HAPPY TO DO IT I'M
I'M I'M GOING BACK. INTO THE A
MEN'S AREN'T IN PRINT PS. BUT I
WANT. I I'D IT MIGHT HELP TO
WALK THROUGH THOSE AT THE VERY
END OF THE ANALYSIS IF YOU GO
TO THE- KIND OF POTPOURRI PAGE
FOR YOU HERE- SIXTEEN OF THE
ANALYSIS- IN ADDITION THE
MEDICAL AND SCIENTIFIC RESEARCH
PIECE- WHICH IS AMENDMENT ONE-
THERE. IS AN AMENDMENT THREE-
THAT A WAY FOR FOLKS TO SHOW
THAT THEY'VE GOT A READILY
AVAILABLE AND EFFECTIVE
TREATMENT- AND THAT THE MAIN
FOCUS IS PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY. THAT THAT IS SORT OF IT
THIS ISN'T DESIGNED TO BE GOING
AFTER. NEWS SANCTUARY THAT'S
THAT'S REALLY NOT THE FOCUS OF
THIS LEGISLATION AND I THINK
I'D BE IN HOT WATER MY OWN
DISTRICT IF THAT WERE THE CASE
BUT AGAIN I WANT TO MAKE GOOD
ON THAT AND- HAPPY TO BRING YOU
OR YOUR STAFF FOR WHOMEVER INTO
THOSE DISCUSSIONS IS. BILL DOES
MOVE ATTY MEDIAN AND
APPROPRIATIONS I APPRECIATE
THAT RESPONSE SENATOR I KNOW
YOU'RE ON IT YOU'RE YOU'RE A
GOOD PERSON WHO WANTS TO TRY TO
GET THE BEST. RESULTS POSSIBLE
AND I ACCEPT THAT. OFFER TO
WORK WITH YOU ON CREATING THAT.
LANGUAGE I THINK. BY THE FACT
THAT ALL OF US ARE- TALKING
ABOUT THE SAME SPECIFIC THING
WERE BEING CONTACTED BY THE
SAME FOLKS- PROBABLY- NOT
KNOWING. EVERYONE'S THINKING
AND WHAT THEY'RE DOING BUT I
CAN SEE THE COMMONALITY YEAR SO
IT MUST BE AN ISSUE OF CONCERN.
FOR THESE FOLKS WITH THESE
TYPES OF FACILITIES ONE FIVE
QUESTION FOR ME CAN YOU KINDA
ADDRESS THE ISSUE. OF THE
POTENTIAL ISSUE OF THE FACT
THAT. THERE MIGHT BE CONFLICT
WITH RESPECT TO THE- THE LAWS.
WITH FEDERAL AND STATE AND THE
FEDERAL. LAWS MIGHT PREEMPT AND
TRUMP THE- THAT THAT THE STATE.
WORK THAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO
HERE CAN YOU. ADDRESS AT A
SPECIAL CENTERS BEEN RULING
ALREADY AT THE- APPEALS COURT.
HERE CALVET THE NINTH. AND KNEW
EACH. FIRST. YEAH SO. THIS BILL
WILL WE PAY CLOSE IT TO THE
LIVING OVER A NEW JERSEY
STACKED AND CRAFTED THE BILL
MERRILY IN A WAY TO AVOID ANY
POTENTIAL PREEMPTION CHALLENGES
OF COURSE WE'VE GOT A SEPARATE
BILL BECAUSE IN THERE TOO SO
THE ARCHITECTURE OF THE BROADER
PUBLIC HEALTH FRAMEWORK AND ALL
THAT SHOULDN'T COLLAPSE IF
THERE IS SOME- I'M KIND OF PRE
EMPTION CHILD THAT IS
SUCCESSFUL BUT IN. THEY REALLY
STARTED INTRUDE ON INTERSTATE
COMMERCE AND LOOKING
SPECIFICALLY AT DEALING WITH
TREATY INTERVENTION BUT I KNOW
WE TALKED A LOT ABOUT
INTERNATIONAL LONG WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT COMMERCE IN IMPORTATIONS
BUT- THIS BILL REALLY. ISN'T
DESIGNED IN THAT SAME WAY.
FURTHERMORE THE NEW JERSEY
STATUE WAS WHEN WAS LITIGATED
THE STATE DECIDED. NOT TO-
THEY'D BE. THE WHAT. IN ANY
THAT WE FEEL LIKE HAVE PRACTICE
FOR A PO ANYTHING ON OUR STATE
HERE SO. I DON'T THINK THE
LITIGATION RISK IS HIGH I THINK
THERE IS LITIGATION WILL WIN.
AND IF WE LOSE AT THE
SEVERABILITY HOPEFUL KEEP THE
REST OF IT GATHER BUT I DON'T
THINK YOU'RE TAKING A BIG
GAMBLE HERE WITH WITH THIS VOTE
HERE TODAY ON ON ON THAT
LITIGATION FOR. BY WAY IF YOU
WANT TO LOOK THAT PAGE FIFTEEN
TO GOOD HAVE SEEN THE ANALYSIS
ON THAT. ON THAT ISSUE THE
COMMITTEE DOES GET A BIT TO.
THAT EXACT QUESTION AND I
THOUGHT THEY PUSHED OUT THAT
THAT ISSUE QUITE WELL SO THAT'S
ON FIFTEEN IF YOU'RE
INTERESTED. NOT I READ THAT
THAT'S WHY I RAISE THE POINT IS
I STILL HAD QUESTION MYSELF BUT
NOT. EVERYONE IS AS MAYBE IT
FIRST IN THAT PARTICULAR PART
OF INTERNATIONAL LAW SO THAT
MIGHT BE THE CASHIER. I
UNDERSTAND. THANK YOU DAN IN
ITS AND AGAIN. NOT WE WERE NOT
GOING TO TOUCH THAT INTERSTATE
COMMERCE AND WE'RE NOT GOING TO
INTERVENE ON THOSE
INTERNATIONAL TREATIES THAT IS
NOT THE- THOSE AREN'T THE
MECHANICS OF THIS BILL. SO
HOPEFULLY IN THAT WITH THAT
SORT OF NARROWING WERE WERE
OKAY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
I YIELD BACK MY TIME SOME
NUMBER WE DO HAVE A MOTION. BY
SOME EVER. KALRA AND A SECOND
BY DOCTOR WOULD I DON'T SEE ANY
OTHER MICROPHONES UP. THE FORTY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS
THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATOR THANK
YOU. SCORE PRESENTING THE OF.
AND EVERYONE WHO CALLED IN- TO
WEIGH IN ON THE ISSUE. OF THE
SCORE WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE. HE
WAS CHAIRMAN I JUST ON THE OF
SENATOR TERRORISTS. ASK THE
MEMBERS I'D VOTE. ALRIGHT THANK
YOU THE MOTION IS A TO PASS-
WITH THE AMENDMENTS RECOMMENDED
THAT IS THE MOTION AND A SECOND
FLOOR. WHICH SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THEROLL. SB ELEVEN SEVENTY
FIVE THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. EDUARDO GARCIA
HI EDUARDO GARCIA HI. MEGHAN
DALLY. MEGAN DALLY NO BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NOT VOTING CHOI. CHOI
NO CHIU. TWO I FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN I CRISTINA GARCIA
CRISTINA GARCIA I GLORIA.
GLORIA HI KALRA KALRA I. LEVINE
LEVINE I MATHIS. MATHIS NO
BLANCA RUBIO. BLANCA RUBIO NOT
VOTING SALAS. WOULD WOOD I. THE
VOTE IS EIGHT TO THREE. VOTE
HAS A BILL HAS ENOUGH VOTES TO
MOVE ON TO CORPORATIONS WERE
GOING TO LEAVE THE CALL OPEN
FOR FIVE MINUTES- FOR FIVE
MINUTES FOR OTHER MEMBERS TO-
COME IN AND OUT ON. THANK YOU.
MR SECTOR I'D LIKE TO OPEN THE
ROLE FOR MEMBERS TO ADD ONTO
THE CONTENT CALENDAR AT THIS
TIME. CALLING THE OF THE
MEMBERS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
SB TWELVE THIRTY ONE. FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN I. VOTERS THIRTEEN
ZERO CURRENTLY THANK YOU WE
WILL NOT KEEP THE CALL OPEN FOR
ANOTHER FOUR MINUTES FOR
MEMBERS TO ADD ON TO THE ACTION
ITEM. OF OUR AGENDA TODAY.
SCHECTER FEEL OPEN UP- THE CALL
FOR THE CONSENT CALENDAR AND
THE ACTION ITEM FOR. CALLING
CALLING THE UP THE MEMBERS ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR SB THIRTY
ONE SALAS. SALAS HI VOTERS
FOURTEEN ZERO. THE BILL WILL
FILL OUT TO COMMITTEE FOR
PATIENTS AND WE HAVE ONE MORE
ITEM. SB ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE
CALLING THE UPS A MEMBERS SALAS.
NOT VOTING SALAS NOT VOTING THE
VOTE IS. EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY
THREE THE BILL MOVES OUT OF THE
COMMITTEE TO APPROPRIATIONS AT
THIS TIME WE WILL RETURN THE
WATER PARKS AND WILDLIFE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU ALL FOR-
INTELLIGENCE AND WHERE CHEN.